Ha freaks and free gets we're back.
We're back with lots of stories because
the internet is filled with a
pleasurable news items.
It's been a fun weekend.
It's been a fun weekend for you.
Brian loves,
uh,
cause I know Brian is sometimes a bit
aimless and when he finds a cause boys
he'd get excited and his cause was this
gentleman across himself,
the fat Jewish or fat Jew depending on
who you ask.
And I,
you know,
what's really fucked up?
I was telling people to check out his
instagram because I'm like,
guys always get some funny stuff on
there.
I didn't even think about where it came
from because to me as a comic,
I guess it's like a self centered thing.
Like I think of like stealing jokes is
like stealing.
Like someone stand up and they do jokes.
I never thought of like memes as jokes,
but they really are.
And a lot of them are from like an
individual page.
Like there's a girl that he stole from.
It's really funny.
And I went to her page and it's all her
own shit.
And she's wizard name.
Uh,
which one are you talking about?
Um,
I've,
I've actually gone through the last 24
hours and have checked over almost 100
different people.
I've been researching
ones that you retweeted.
One of the ones that I retweeted that
you put up,
it was a girl,
attractive young lady with dark brown
hair.
Find it real quick,
but a point being these people,
they,
you know,
before Brian was a standup comic when I
met Brian,
Brian do like really funny videos and
there was a time where you,
what is her name?
God dammit.
Princess of Wifi.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Hilarious.
Yeah.
And it's super funny because I'd never
even realized it's a smart one where she
posts a bunch of emojis and it's this
shout out to the snail for facing the
other way.
And because the one emoji animal that's
not facing the same way as the snail,
and so he pretty much just copied every
single thing she did and put it on a,
on his thing and didn't credit her.
Yeah.
And it's time stamped.
And that's another thing.
Nowadays,
everything's timestamped.
And so when I've been researching all
these,
a lot of people have already researched
this guy because he's been doing this
for awhile.
It's just never caught fire so fast as
it did this weekend.
Well,
we were talking about you before you,
before I met you,
you were kind of like a comedian on the
Internet before the Internet was like
that popular,
like you'd make funny videos and that's
how we became friends.
Um,
but like that thing that people don't
think of that as being a comedian,
like you think of a comedian has to go
on stage.
Not really,
because if you're this girl or this guy
right here,
Devin,
that's actually an original person I
found out this has been reported as
Davin Magwood being the one that
originally wrote this lion tweet,
which is going to start dressing like a
lion.
So the cops know that if they kill me,
white people will avenge me.
Uh,
that was actually written by something.
Somebody completely different,
uh,
and uh,
that persons are gay on twitter.
Roxane gay.
And
I retweet this guy,
stole it from her,
from her,
and he was complaining that he wasn't
getting credit.
Yeah.
No really.
I mean this just happened.
I don't know though.
We don't know the.
Is that what the timestamp true.
The timestamp on our gay is July 29th.
Two Thousand 15.
And devins is July 29th at nine.
Oh,
four.
Nine.
Oh,
5:00
PM is his in 11:44
AM is hers.
Oh,
so he saw that day and stole it?
Yeah.
Allegedly.
Unless,
although she reads minds time traveling
north or that's what I was going to say.
Or is she like,
lives in Japan and he lives in Hawaii or
something because the timestamp work
locally though,
doesn't it work locally?
It was going to work in.
Yeah,
it does.
Yeah.
It doesn't work like that.
I'm just kidding.
Yeah.
Well that's fucked up that people are
claiming they got stolen from.
And how do people not know that this is
going to get out?
Well,
the thing I,
I've heard of fat Jew for a bit and uh,
he's been thrown on Tmz a lot.
He's been thrown on all these shows.
He's one of those guys that I've always
got like,
how is this guy here whose mom and dad
is,
you know,
this guy.
But then,
uh,
then somebody,
he got signed to ca,
which is one of the biggest talent
agencies here in Los Angeles.
And that immediately all the comedians
came out of the woodwork,
like,
wait a second,
I can't even pay my rent,
and this guy's just got signed a comedy
central deal,
a book,
a music deal with apple.
He has his own show on apple beats one,
which is their new radio station.
So they have a dj who's just a
plagiarist on,
on their brand new fresh station.
Uh,
yeah.
So,
uh,
there's actually been so many reports
like from like New York News,
Washington Post,
all these places have actually reported
about him being a plagiarist for awhile.
But it's,
it's been one of those things where
everyone kind of knew,
but it never,
the Internet never caught on.
And so this is amazing because there's
one report,
uh,
which is,
you have to check out this website.
I sent it to you.
Uh,
it's on storify,
it's top 50 jokes,
the fat Jewish bogarted from the
Internet and this was written,
it's just 50 joke now again,
there's 19 hours ago.
So this is new to.
This was all coming out while this was
all going down.
Yeah.
And now the first one is obviously wrong
that they have on there.
And this is one thing that I've been
doing the last couple of days I've
actually been taking these,
uh,
if you just put this much energy in your
own life,
he would be so much healthier.
Everything would be great.
You wouldn't be totally off smoke and
you'd be going to the gym on a regular
basis.
Your drinking water.
Right.
But you know,
with the car lisman see a video.
I did that overnight when that happened
and it's,
it's an obsession when,
when it's something that's unique and,
and,
and I feel like people need to know
about and this to me is something I
can't believe has been going on for so
long.
And when I went to the store last night
and everyone goes,
oh yeah,
I know about that guy.
Yeah,
he sucks.
I'm like,
wait,
you haven't heard what's been going on
lately?
Sandy,
Dan toe,
he who's a comedian,
a comedy store comic,
a paid regular.
He actually had a bit of his that,
his standup bit that he had taken and
made it a meme and then he called him
out on it in the comments and like a
couple hours later he deleted it.
And the same thing happened to Amir Kay,
who is another comedian.
Uh,
so it's,
it's a lot of comics.
I know about this.
What he does have a bunch of interns or
writer or a bunch of employees.
Well,
that's what he's been claiming for about
the last,
I think five years.
Uh,
he's been claiming that he has employees
and,
and all these people working on his
website,
but you know,
that's,
that excuse might happen once or twice,
but you know what,
look,
this is literally here is 50 of them and
I've already found them
could happen.
It could happen more than that.
The thing about saying it once or twice,
it's like,
no,
I'm not trying to stick up for this guy.
But the reality of like Sitcom writers,
like Seinfeld stole,
not Seinfeld the man,
but the show stole one of Kevin James
Bits and did it on their episode.
And this is when Kevin James was not
known.
Kevin was a friend of mine.
Still is,
but it was back then and Kevin hadn't
made it yet.
He hadn't,
it wasn't.
He had an uncanny queens.
He'd won star search,
you know,
and he'd been like on a couple of
different TV shows.
Um,
and he had a big deal with NBC,
like a development deal dues on sitcoms.
So I was there,
I went with them,
he did the showcase for all these NBC
writers.
So,
but these showcases are like,
they do these sitcoms things where they
would sit down and they would bring,
you know,
all the show runners from very shows
that have deals with them and they say,
Hey,
we got this guy,
his name's Kevin James.
We just signed.
And it was really funny.
We want you guys to watch him do stand
up and tell us what you think.
So they watched him do standup and then
they stole his bit.
And use it as an episode of Seinfeld,
the bit about Muffin tops.
Oh yeah.
Kevin James.
It was one of his signature bits and
this was a long ass time ago and it was
before the show and it's not the first
time that happened.
That happened a gang of times.
It happened a bunch of times with a
bunch of different comics on a bunch of
different shows.
They would have their signature bits
turned into m,
two M plotlines on sitcoms or gags on in
living color was a big one.
Like a lot of guys claim that some of
the writers from in living color would
come down to the comedy store.
Watch guys do stand up like handyman
someone.
Someone said that handyman was something
that was stolen from.
Not the Damon had stolen it,
but some writer it stolen it.
I don't know if that's true or not,
but there's a lot of those things that
happen when they think they can get away
with it.
Especially if they can go down to the
comedy store on open mic night.
Yeah.
That's what a lot of people there.
So many random people that come to these
open mic,
uh,
places that just sit there with their
notepads,
just writing everything down or writing
math.
You should be smacked.
You want to sit in the back
of the comedy store?
Let me look.
They could always record it and then you
know,
people do that on their phones.
Anyway,
there was going to record sets.
Just got to,
in this day and age you got to assume
and when I was first starting out,
you have to have a fucking actual tape
recorder.
Couldn't just sit in your pocket.
Like you could have your phone in your
jacket pocket and no one would know and
it could be recording.
As long as the mic is up,
it comes out crystal clear.
I've done it in my back pocket like I've
done sets and just record it and stuff
that in my back pocket to see what it
would sound like.
I can hear everything.
Everything.
Did anyone ever used to take the old
like radio shack,
box interview,
private investigator,
tape recorder like that,
you know,
the huge microphone and just sit it on
the stool.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
I definitely saw people do that.
Um,
I actually used to have one that was a,
a mini disc recorder.
Who will fuck taught me how to do that.
Somebody,
somebody taught me about it.
He had it clipped to his belt.
Uh,
I'll try to remember who the dude is and
give them credit,
but he had a mini district porter
clipped his belt and then he had a line
that ran up to like a little lapel mic
and he would do all the sets like that
and then store them all in many disks.
So I had a mini disc recorder installed
in the comedy store so I could just
record the sets and listened to on me
desk and then we switched over to dat
and then we switched over to cd when you
could burn cds and now I don't even know
if that's still there.
So they still have that CD setup where
you can burn your copy of it.
I don't even know anymore.
Is it even necessary at all anymore?
Nah,
Nah.
Phones are just as good.
I mean,
unless you want to get something that's
the quality that you could release as an
album because you could get it.
Definitely have it set up.
You just have the microphone.
Um,
some parts of the audience mic like a
couple spots might.
But um,
what was my point?
Point being?
How the fuck did we get here?
Oh,
about how uh,
Kevin James.
So they steal.
So if he had employees,
if the fat Jew had,
I feel weird calling them that
I actually enjoy it.
And this particular only time
you're allowed to say the fat Jew,
but I feel like someone's going to take
this shit out of context.
It's kind of a hack though.
I'll just going to call them the fat
Jewish.
It seems like less overall statement.
It seems like a superhero.
The Fat Jewish,
but he could easily have employees but
hasn't even been proven that he has an
employee's.
And where's this guy getting the money
to hire employees?
The other thing I was looking at on his
page was he would talk about how much
money he's making off of it.
Instagram.
I saw Katie Kirk and he was doing this
interview and I was like,
that's weird.
I go out because I don't see like a lot
of product placement,
so I went to his inner instagram to try
to find product placement.
I can tell you everything and it's funny
that you said how you didn't say,
why is Katie couric interviewing this
guy,
the fat Jew.
How'd that even happen?
Because he has so many instagram
followers.
Yeah,
that's why.
But I was thinking he has his own wine
company,
so like the famous picture of him
pouring two bottles of his own wine on
his chest.
That's his own wine is a.
This is independent of his instagram,
right?
Yes,
but so what he does is he mixes all
these into it and then he's also done
burger king,
chicken fries and ads and he also
reportedly has done ads where he can
delete them within a certain amount of
time so he can just post a picture of
him,
you know,
enjoying a delicious white castle burger
and then they deleted in 20 minutes.
That's pretty smart.
Most of them don't leave those ads up.
They'll delete them within a week or so.
They're up on their feed and what's
interesting and what's really
interesting is that his wife slash
girlfriend or whatever,
she's works at tinder as their head of a
publicist,
a publicist for tender.
When she she is trained to do.
When I dated a publicist,
all she did was like telling me all
these secrets,
like,
no,
you can do this and do that and do that.
Their whole life is how to make money
off of social media and get noticed on
social media.
So he has not only a wine company s
somebody said he has a,
a,
a tee shirt company a and he's got a
bunch of different little companies that
he just intertwines into his instagram
to make it look like he's just doing so.
He's like the Ryan seacrest of like just
joke thievery and getting shit right.
Promoted his.
His one's constantly got a bunch of toes
in the game.
Yeah.
He has another famous picture which has
him laying in a pool drinking out of a
pool that has his own wine in it.
Kind of a copy of that.
A kind of a copy of that show will get
us pulled down here,
right?
Last Man on earth is a from that movie,
so he's even stealing his ideas for
pitchers to sell his wind from TV shows.
He's using Reddit,
he's going on websites.
What his formula is,
and there's a couple people that
actually do that.
This.
He's not the only one.
There's another guy a fuck jerry who was
another almost as bad if not worse,
a guy and what they do is they just go
to reddit or they just go to any of
these websites,
find the number one trending thing at
that second,
try to find the meat in it,
take the meat,
throw it on a picture of a black
cheeseburger,
and then you,
you go,
you have it.
Well,
I'm glad.
That's pretty much what the formula like
if you.
You look for the funniest thing,
a thread at different websites.
What has most fused most posts with that
day they take out,
steal that idea and then mix it with
something else is what he does the most
where he'll just take a photo of a fat
chick or something like that,
but or whatever and put,
put the two together or.
But what he's mostly he does is somebody
else does that exact same thing and then
he just takes it word from word and the
pitcher crops,
the name out doesn't give any credit and
just throws it up there.
I've seen that and that's,
that's like one of those things where
you could say like maybe somebody sent
it to him and he just didn't know who
made it,
so he just posted it,
but not if you change all the words and
put them in your own handwriting or your
own font rather because he's done that
before too.
Yeah.
Well it's,
it's interesting because what I was
getting at earlier is that I never
thought of like an internet
comedian.
Whoops.
I never thought of an internet comedian
as being the same as a comedian,
but you clearly are like the young lady
that we talked about.
What the fuck's her name again?
Well,
it's,
it's the same as your audience.
Uh,
I have to go back.
We've got to shoot name deep and now so
we know.
Uh,
but drew drew,
drew to do,
what is it one of the ones that I
retweeted from you.
Oh,
princess wifey,
princess of Wifi.
Um,
that these,
you know,
these people are working,
they're creating these things like this
and then they get a lot of like our
friend slash lien from up in Canada.
Hilarious and got famous just from
writing funny shit on twitter and then
got a gang of like organically got a
gang of twitter followers just because
she writes funny stuff and I'm sure
she's been ripped off.
I can't even tell you people have.
She's,
I think she tried doing stand up at one
point in time,
but she didn't for a long time.
There's a lot of people that would read
her shit and go,
this could be a really funny bit.
I could take this and turn into a bit,
so I guarantee you that's happened.
Yeah.
And it's happened in a ton of time with
just normal people.
I think we've probably all done it
before.
Even my mom's probably posted a photo
that she didn't make,
have some quote that she didn't write of
footsteps from Jesus or something.
But like the big difference between this
and us doing it is this,
he's directly getting paid to do this.
He's directly,
uh,
creating a business and an empire based
on only plagiarism.
Well,
he's,
what he's doing is he's taking a lot of
us think of as innocent,
which is,
you know,
you send me something.
I retweeted,
we all do that,
but he's doing it like in a creepy way
too,
because I used the repost app so it
shows I repost things.
Like every time I repost something it's
with a repost app unless someone sends
it to me and I can't figure out where it
came from.
And then I had one of those and I
deleted it.
I deleted recently.
Well,
what if black people have been gold this
whole time?
I was like,
that's not mine.
It's funny,
it's a funny meme,
but I'm like,
I have to delete it now because we're
doing this whole thing.
Like I never trying to profit off of
that,
but I thought about it.
I was like,
that's somebody else's work and I don't
want to get it twisted with me.
So I deleted that.
Now that all this was going on,
I was like,
well,
I can't be a hipper.
Right.
It's interesting how sensitive every
single thing is getting.
What's the difference though?
I mean,
it's really all about intent.
that's what it is,
right?
Yeah.
It's really interesting.
I've been doing so much research on this
guy that I didn't.
One thing I know it,
uh,
that episode of workaholics where he's a
pod at forward,
the one that they talked about Joe Rogan
Isms in it.
A lot fat Jew has a cameo in that for no
apparent reason at all.
They look over and he's like doing
pushups on the ground and that's it.
So He's been working his way into
Hollywood.
He has a video that's on youtube.
It's called fat Jew nude on shrooms in
Mexico where he's just shooting guns,
uh,
and running around naked on mushrooms
and then driving at the end.
But it's,
there's a lot of interesting videos.
There's another video,
this news morning news place had him on
the morning news and he was,
this was right before his instagram was
starting to take off a little and he was
with his manager and some other person
all being interviewed and I wish I could
find.
I've been looking for it if I find I can
show it,
send it to you.
But it's interesting because he kind of
put it down like yes,
no,
they,
the secret to what I'm doing is just
posting a bunch of funny stuff or buts
and then getting tons of money from it.
And then like he just broke it down.
So like if I ever make a video of this
guy,
I put that aside at my house because
there's so many amazing quotes from the
interview and it's really weird.
Is his manager,
whoever was sitting next to him.
She's like,
yeah,
we're going to make all this money out
and we're going to make all this money,
and then there's a guy the black at the
end go.
What still good.
I don't think this is what.
I think instagram is good for our health
and fitness and a lot of things,
not just buckets.
There's one of those morning news guys.
Those guys are always wrong.
That's where their morning news guys.
But it was an interesting interview.
So much interesting thing I've been
looking through for the last couple of
days on this guy.
So his comedy central pilot got canceled
so that,
that was announced,
uh,
that comedy central confirmed that they
have to.
How did they,
not if they're after them and see a
thing.
Yeah,
because they kept men Sia on after that
show.
And his ratings dropped by more than 50
percent instantly.
And then like,
oh Christ.
And then also they knew,
they knew what the fuck he did,
you know,
and then they have a show on and they
also knew,
and this was a big one,
that the fucking show was responsible
for plagiarism.
I'll a lot of it,
a lot of it,
and Lewis black was fucking furious
because Lewis Black was on comedy
central,
so he was on the Jon Stewart show and
while he's on the Jon Stewart show,
he's been stealing is doing his shit and
not only just doing it but doing it like
this with the fingers the way that told
a bit like Lewis,
I mean he's literally doing Louis Shit
on the same network loses on,
so they.
They took a fuck load of heat for that.
Plus there's a new regime at comedy
central now and they're way smarter and
they're just there.
They're on the ball as far as like their
choices.
That's why you seen shows like Amy
Schumer's show like Hannibal Burress,
like Ari there,
you're seeing good show and taking
chances from real comedians for once.
It's.
Yeah,
it's still have their online platform,
which they've been really smart about
developing too though,
like this is not happening.
They started out as an online platform.
Then they brought it to a television
after they work it out that way.
So there's very little pressure on it.
It's smart.
They're doing everything the right way,
so they're like,
fuck this dude,
you know this,
you just can't do that.
You can't do it.
I don't know if it was him or if it was
as employees.
We don't really don't know.
He's asked to take responsibility for
it,
especially if it's happened in large
institutions writing about it.
You know what I mean?
You
know?
Yeah.
No,
keep going like that.
He
has to take responsibility for that
because he is the one getting the
paychecks for all this.
Even if his interns,
which are probably unpaid interns is
what I'm guessing a.
You have to do it.
What I thought was interesting as Brian
[inaudible],
Hennie Hennigan a wrote something
interesting because he has a book coming
out and he goes,
did fat Jew sign an affidavit for grand
central pub,
hatchet us that his new book is all his
own work.
Wonder why they're helping a plagiarist.
I mean that comes different to when it
comes to authors and books and stuff
like that because you,
you're selling words and
on the ball as your manager.
I know he won't do it.
You can only have one client,
especially,
it's Doug Stanhope,
he's got holes in his stomach,
was intestines poke through,
he can lay on his back and forces
intestines through holes in his
abdominal wall that I love him,
but he's not going to make it.
Well,
I told,
I told Brian that I had alive.
I mean,
he's obviously made it as a comedian.
Brian I call shotgun.
All right.
Here's the thing.
This fat Jewish guy has not posted
anything in many hours,
which is very rare.
Like his last one is 18 hours ago.
So while this is all going down,
he's a,
he's sworn off of the,
uh,
the instagram.
The other thing is you look at it,
the recent posts,
like one of them that he stole from
that,
a princess of Wifi or.
No,
that's the other one.
This is another girl who's hilarious.
This is the one I was actually thinking
of.
Pistol Sherman is her name a s c h u r
a.
she's fucking hilarious.
Her,
her,
all.
Her instagram feed is shit that she's
made.
I assume.
I mean,
I'm not,
I'm not 100 percent sure,
but I'm pretty sure it's all her work
and it's really fucking funny.
Like she's just a funny comic like,
or funny at writing this stuff.
Whatever it is,
you know,
whatever you want to call her.
Um,
so he's got a bit that he took from her,
the international hand symbol for what
the hell is this guy doing?
She's got this thing like what w,
which is true.
So he takes that.
He puts it up and then he just writes
her name on the bottom.
That's it.
See it,
see that he's got it here.
That's her.
But if you go to his,
all he does is he took,
he took it and he put,
he puts his own bullshit in it.
Um,
and when he puts his own bullshit in it,
he puts her name at the bottom.
He doesn't even say created by.
He just tags her.
Yeah.
And he supposedly has been adding tags
to all his last week.
It's the fat Jewish story.
There's so much going on.
It's not the fat Jew is the fat Jewish.
Yeah.
See that one down there?
The Middle One?
Yeah.
Okay,
so you click on that.
It's got 209,000
likes.
By the way,
the most I've ever gotten.
I think maybe I got like 25,000
likes ever.
Well he's got over $5 million on
instagram.
I know it's incredible.
But look what he did there.
So he takes this and look at.
He wrote you guys,
this is funny because it's relatable and
we all share these types of human
experiences in parentheses.
Sorry I'm on molly.
No you're not.
And then at Pistol Sherman.
So he stole her thing and then he sorta
just sorta tags her but it doesn't say
created by and then under the theory say
posting stolen joke from the person you
credit also clearly stole it.
Oh,
what the person you credit also clearly
stole it.
Really?
See that's the problem and it's,
it's,
I've been noticed when I've been doing
is as I've taken the photo and cropped
it out and then re uploaded it to google
images and tried to find the first time
stamped that you.
Cause they can search by photo and
Colin's trait,
FBI,
I mean one,
one of these took me over an hour just
to find out who really made it and it
turned out at the gym.
You can stare machine.
It's true.
I'll help and I know what's wrong with
me.
I need to stop.
And you do upset.
It's funny though.
I started,
I had a big smile on my face when I
started getting texts from you and then
when I saw the patent was retweeting
your stuff and I said all right,
I'm in.
I started retweeting it too.
I'm like fuck it,
let's just,
let's pile on.
So he doesn't even say this is what bugs
me.
Sorry,
I'm on Molly,
whatever.
And then at Pistol Sherman.
So I don't know whether or not this girl
didn't write it or did write it.
But the point is he thinks she wrote it
and instead of crediting her,
he just writes her name.
It doesn't even like write original by
got this from,
you know,
this is hilarious.
I found it on her page.
She just has her name there.
That doesn't mean anything,
like I put people's names at the bottom
of their list so they'll see it or
something.
I mean,
I don't.
It gets deeper than enough.
It gets deeper than the Nacho.
I got deep into this one thread I got.
I got deepen this one thread that even
had proof of him making fake twitter
accounts and just taking jokes and
having that fake person tweet them and
then him crediting the fake twitter
account that he owns.
Oh,
oh no.
You sure?
How do you know that,
man?
It's a lot.
It's a whole message board page or
Reddit page or something like that.
Read it.
Read.
It's been on this for a while though.
So that's what's great about that.
Uh,
that it's now finally,
I think the Internet is now catching
onto this whole thing.
Wow.
They definitely are today.
And the fact that he hasn't made a post
in 18 hours and if you look before that,
he was making like five,
six of them a day.
They were like rapid fire.
That was the thing that was funny about
us page.
You would constantly see some pretty
silly shit.
I got to stop following them on
instagram.
I think I'm still following them right
now.
Somebody told me that already.
Then I'm still following.
Yeah,
fucking tattle tales.
And it was really weird as he steals
from people that if he had any common
sense that you
would not steal from Matt Besser.
I don't know if you know Matt Besser
from back in the days.
He's old school.
He,
I think he's one of the founders of UCB
or if not the founder of UCB.
Uh,
he stole from him.
He put it.
How many potheads does it take to screw
in a light bulb?
None.
We're trying to keep it mellow here.
Funny Little Joke.
Fat Jews stole it.
And that's like in the comedy world,
that's like insane.
If you steal from Matt,
that's.
Yeah,
well there's a lot of people out there
that don't know who he is and they think
that they can get away with it.
That's what he's doing.
I mean,
what he's doing,
he got away with up until now when you
get away with something for that long
and it's that profitable.
You know,
how many people have been mad at him for
that or you're stealing money from
people really see what you're doing.
Yeah,
I mean the.
Or are they making money?
It's a weird situation because it's like
some people just doing it for fun and
then you're profiting off of their fun.
But that's Kinda like there was um,
there was an artist once that was taking
photos of other people's are and then
drawing like pretty much exact
duplicates of it.
It was like a cartoon and it's happened
many times.
But uh,
there was one story that was on this one
cartoon that this guy was doing where he
had stolen like so many of,
uh,
this guy's images and just put his own
version of it,
but like so similar and some people were
trying to figure out how this guy can
get away with this for so long,
but I think there's just too much to pay
attention to for you to connect the dots
on two different images like that.
Like,
and he probably was dumb or ridiculous
or thought he can get away with it.
This is his last post right here.
Yes.
It's actually watermarked with that name
at Burt Bondi.
It's funny you say that,
Jamie,
because this is the one that took me in
one of the ones that took me over half
hour to research that you think is the,
the,
the original line was looking at his
page too and yeah,
it seems like the guy has his twitter
name is actually in the pitcher Joe and,
but he didn't credit the guy even though
his name is actually in there.
Uh,
so that's one of the fake ones.
Well,
that's one that I researched and found
out that there was actually somebody
before that person.
So that person tagged his name in it,
saying it was his,
when it wasn't even his.
And that could be one of the ones where
he,
he banked it.
What is this right now?
What are you looking at?
Oh,
Bert bonded from supposedly,
yeah,
supposedly.
But this guy,
somebody else had it before him.
That's what it looks like.
It was weird.
I was my point.
I was going to bring up on this.
It's kind of weird because this is where
you get into like parody law and
copyright,
like they're taking photographers photos
and making money off of them without
paying the photographer,
but because it's parody you're actually
allowed to do that to a certain extent.
So at what point are you allowed to
parody a joke and that's okay.
Yeah,
but you can't word for word it,
but I know.
See I'm torn here.
Here's why I'm torn.
I love memes.
I think these are fucking hilarious.
Like I enjoy them
when when someone sends me a funny one
or when I get a funny one on instagram
and I scroll through it and I laugh with
them.
I like them.
That's all I have to,
but I want people to keep but I don't
know.
I don't want to necessarily like.
I don't want to discredit the fact that
someone made it,
but I don't really give a fuck that
someone made it like I do now.
Even as book cover fat Jew as a stupid
book.
Even as far as look cover is a copy of
the Steve Jobs Book.
Well,
I think that's on pop on appropriate.
I know,
but it's just funny that everything he
does is completely unoriginal and fake.
Who the hairstyle was?
Hairstyle.
That's like a kung po from the
kickboxer.
Moving Tong Po.
Remember that guy?
John Claude van Damme before I'd spend
the end,
got the crazy haircut.
I just got to kind of a tongue po thing
going on.
Was there?
Yeah.
So,
um,
you're not his friend,
is that what you're trying to say?
Do you know what?
I just,
I,
I'm just amazed by it.
I'm just shocked by.
I don't like it when I see my friends of
mine that he's stolen from it and I'm
just like,
why am I just finding out about this guy
now?
And then I remember when I heard his
name around on TMZ and twitter and all
that,
I just didn't want to ever click on the
link because I'm just like,
I don't care about this fat Jew guy,
you know,
like I don't give a shit.
But then now I kind of want to stop it
so I don't have to see more of him,
you know,
in the future.
Well,
it didn't bother me when I saw him
before.
I thought,
well this is interesting.
This guy's figuring out how to profit
off of these memes.
And I was saying,
I'm wonder if this is going to be like
something that happens in the future.
And then I thought,
well what he's doing is just going
finding pictures and then they say funny
shit and put it on the picture.
It was he,
that's how he was describing it.
And he was saying it to Katie couric
that he has a staff and they go,
they comb the Internet for funny things,
but really they're just ganking memes
and he's doing it as a corporation.
He's doing it like as a business.
One of the ones that he did,
it went the farthest back as being the
oldest joke I could find.
He found off of a 2001 a website that
still existed.
And this might not even be the first
one,
but it was one of those news mail,
email newsletters that you would send,
like,
here's Alicia funny jokes,
ha.
And it's just a list of like 50 jokes.
And he just started taking from that
list as one of them.
I can't say I'm shocked.
Right?
I mean,
now that you know his modus operandi,
the other thing that I've,
I've heard him talk and they never seems
funny.
You know,
like when I'm hearing him talk,
I'm like,
this guys doesn't seem like a funny guy.
You know,
like if you,
you know,
Kevin Pereira,
let's use him as an example.
You know,
if Kevin was on some show there,
you would listen to him talk and you'd
go,
even if he wasn't trying to be funny,
he would say,
well,
here's a guy that I,
I could see that I'd be funny.
I could see him have a clever point on
something.
Like if someone presented him with an
ecological point of view,
he would be like,
that's,
that doesn't make any sense.
You started making fun of it.
That's his instinct.
That is,
uh,
you know,
your instinct comics instincts and he
did.
Anybody that you have on,
that's a funny person would say funny
shit.
He never seemed funny.
It seems like this like corporate guy or
something,
you know,
this wacky haircut.
It's like a tall package.
Well,
I mean,
what people are telling me is that he
was one of those.
He grew up in a super rich family.
It's been kind of just thrown and given
favors and that's one of those guys,
one of those motherfuckers.
I guess the problem is I could make that
argument about myself not being funny
sometimes too,
if I'm doing something serious,
like if I do a conversation,
especially if it's about mma.
Right?
But then I would,
I'm doing it about that I guess.
Yeah.
But if you listen to a lot of his
interviews,
because I've watched a lot,
he pretty much repeats the same stuff.
Like I just need to get a guacamole and
a in a bathtub and a wine.
Well,
let's see what happened.
Ca,
right?
You're the folks who signed mints,
Delia,
after all that shit went down.
They are.
Yeah.
They took them from Gersh,
they ganged them from grocery at the
worst moment ever.
Wow.
Yeah.
Right.
When the shit was hitting the fan,
they jumped in with a dick in their
hand.
That's insane.
But who knows.
I mean they probably,
I don't think they were aware in the
entirety of the situation that you're
dealing with that and I think there
probably weren't aware about this guy
either because,
look,
I wasn't aware.
I didn't even think of it.
I ignorantly,
it was like,
ah,
I just takes beams,
puts them up there.
I didn't even think about it as
plagiarism,
but when pat and wrote it and then when
you had.
And then I saw the actual instances,
I was like,
oh,
okay.
I see what's going on here.
Yeah,
he is.
He's definitely.
And it wasn't just reposting.
See,
he could have got the same success by
reposting,
you know,
I repost stuff.
If you post something funny and I want
to repost it,
I go to the repost APP.
I repost that and I do it specifically
so that people will know that it came
from you and hopefully they'll click on
your link and sign up and be one of your
followers or whatever.
That's what you're supposed to do.
That's kind of the spirit of the
Internet.
You know,
when someone says something funny,
I always retweet stuff.
I never copy and paste someone's tweet,
you know,
I just don't unless,
unless you have their name in the tweet
as well,
you know,
and then you put in the quote marks,
but other than that,
but then then you know,
everybody knows it comes from them.
But other than that I use a retweet or
repost app or quote tweet,
you know,
you quoted if you using the APP on the
phone,
this is a,
you know,
it's just unethical.
It's unethical and it's against the
spirit of what the Internet is supposed
to be.
All about.
The free exchange of information.
Somebody comes in and just fucking
sticks a syringe in this pipeline of
information.
Just starts pulling it out and then
profiting,
you know,
that's what they're doing instead of
contributing,
instead of like jumping into this free
exchange and then offering up a
successful pipeline.
See,
because this guy could have been a
successful pipeline for all these people
and I bet he would have still got nearly
the same amount of tweets,
are nearly the same amount of likes and
followers and all that jazz.
If he was just a,
you know,
if you just gave everybody
credit and then people would like you,
they wouldn't be mad.
What's interesting is both twitter and
Instagram,
I've heard hire a band him in the past
and with instagram they,
he tied his.
He tied himself up to their headquarters
until they let him back in.
What?
Yeah.
Supposedly I mean bag.
Yeah,
probably.
But it worked and a lot of people have
been trying to tell people to.
Twitter has that new copyright thing
where you can copyright tweets or
whatever and.
But you have to be the originator of
that joke in order to do it.
So there's only people if these people
stood up and go,
no,
I thought that.
And made that and read,
wrote that.
Would they have any,
you know,
they,
to do that or whatever.
Do you remember when that guy was
stealing patrice o'neal's material and
do it as Youtube rants?
And then he was trying to say that he
did it because it was an homage to
portray.
Was trying to pretend he did it like all
angry too.
It was like so gross and fake the way he
did it,
you know,
he's like channeling patrice or
something while he did it and trying to
be smart.
And everybody's like,
oh you fuck,
you're a thief.
You know you,
you're a liar too.
Like the way you're doing it.
You're lying to all these people that
thought you came up with these ideas.
These are not your ideas at all.
It's hard to come back from that.
From that.
You can come back for that.
You can't.
The only way you can come back from that
is to admit that you did that.
Talk about how you did it and then you
got to reestablish yourself as being
completely original.
Good fucking luck.
We've talked about this before with joke
thieves.
It's like there's a bunch of guys that
were joke thieves and one of the things
that you could clearly see,
you could see the difference between
their material and other people's
material.
The other people's material was funny
and then in between there like this
funny shit,
they would have their shit and like
stand out like a sore thumb.
Like there's a guy,
I don't need to mention his name,
everybody knows who the fuck I'm talking
about who stole a lot of shit from Bill
Hicks and he had one good special and
then his second special was hot dog
shit.
I mean it was terrible.
It was like a parody of his first
special is because there was no content
in it because he had burned all these
bridges,
stole all this content,
was scared and sad.
You know,
I'll do it myself,
I'll make my own shit.
But he couldn't make his own shit.
His new shit was terrible.
And there's like this really clear
difference between the two of them.
And I maintained.
It's because the mindset of creativity
is the exact opposite of the mindset of
plagiarism because plagiarism is like,
I want to pretend that this is all my
idea.
I want to pretend to take this and I'm
going to go get all the love for it.
I'm going to get.
Whereas like a comic,
like a hilarious person is like,
what?
What's funny?
Where's the funny?
What is it?
Is it this?
Is it that like you've got.
You're not thinking about you like what
all you are.
You're this vessel for getting the idea
in its best form.
You're like a a boat that carries the
joke to the people.
You got to figure out how the fuck do I
do this?
Like how many times have any of us
had been sitting around going,
I gotta figure out a better way to set
this up or there's a better way to do
this or do you got to figure out this?
Or if someone comes along and just yanks
that and just doesn't have any of the
process,
they don't know how to do that.
They don't know how to do it.
Like that process of creating is like
learning a language and when those
fucking joke,
these have to go out and relearn the
language.
They're essentially like open minker's
and we've seen a couple guys that we
know of that are like that,
that got hot from stealing stuff.
But then if you see him now you're like,
where did the fucking creativity go?
Or they don't stop.
Like our old friend who I found out the
other day that a steel steel's I can't
say.
I'm shocked.
I can't say.
I'm sure.
I don't know.
Tosh.
Yeah,
I don't think he knows how to write.
I don't think he does it and I think
he's scared to bomb as one of the things
that he had always said.
He's like a lot of comics.
Talk about Hubby bummed.
I never bombed.
I bombed all the time,
you know?
You know why?
Because I write stuff.
I try shit out.
Like I,
when you,
when you're writing all the time,
man,
you,
you're gonna fucking have some duds.
You're going to throw them out there and
you gotta go fuck.
And it might,
it's,
you know,
it's not going to be all of them,
but it might be one out of 10 you just
to cut off and throw it into the ocean.
So there's no good.
It's never working.
But there's a lot of people are gonna.
See you do that bit until you decide
that it sucks,
you know you're going to fuck around
with it.
You going to try because sometimes I
don't know if you do those,
but I do.
I know doc does it.
A lot of guys do this where you kind of
like set yourself up in a position where
you really don't know where this bit's
going to go.
You know,
something funny in it.
So you hope that it comes out on stage.
And so there's ways of writing where you
sit down,
smoke a joint suit in front of a
computer or your notebook.
Just fucking trying to figure out how to
do it.
Like I'll,
I'll,
I'll play little games with myself.
I'll say like brian red band is to
Jamie,
like a Walrus is
two.
No peacock.
Let's try to find ways that this subject
interacts with it,
trying to find,
not because of fashion years peacock,
because I'm pretty cocked,
but you know what I'm saying.
Like I'll,
I'll,
I'll do little tricks.
I'll set up lists.
This is like that and I'll do like a
list of different things because I want
to try to find out what the best bit is,
but sometimes you just got to go on
stage and sometimes you go on stage with
this premise and you're pretty sure
there's something funny about this
premise,
but you don't know where it's going to
lead and then boom,
when you're on stage,
the jokes like the punchline will reveal
itself to you or the angle will reveal
itself to you and then you record.
It's like you take this little ember
ticket back to the lab and you fucking
put some tinder.
Tinder on it.
Kindling.
What does it kill?
What's tinder?
Tinder is that APP,
but is it.
But it's a thing too,
right?
Publicist chick doesn't have something
to do with fire tender.
Yeah,
that's what it is.
Tinder,
I think.
Tinder box.
Yeah,
it is.
Oh sorry,
Jesus Christ,
you don't know shit.
Cindy Archer
for fires.
We're talking about fires.
You fuck the point being that that's a
whole process.
You have to learn how to do and if you
don't learn how to create like you,
your video editing,
if you you have to,
you gotta learn how to do that.
You have to do some that you didn't
like.
You got to do something like you.
If you go back and look at your earlier
videos like they weren't as good as your
later videos.
You got better at it.
As time went on,
especially when you start doing it,
you know all the time,
you just get smoother.
It's the same with everything.
Those guys are fucked because their
mind,
it's a wrong mindset,
so they become superstars,
but they're not good.
They're not real.
They live.
It's like being a superstar track and
field athlete,
but you really don't run fast at all.
Like everybody thinks like,
God damn,
this guy's like the fastest guy ever.
But you know,
you've been just been like teleporting
down the fucking down the path and
stealing people's spots and pretending
that you're in first place,
you know,
and just running through the ribbon I
will on.
And they was like,
damn,
that dude's fast.
He won again.
But you didn't really want.
You can't really run fast.
It's almost the exact same thing with
people who are plagiarists.
They lose,
they literally don't have the
creativity.
They've never developed it.
It's Kinda fucked.
It's got to be terrifying.
It's got to be fucking really terrifying
because like Charlie Murphy,
one of the ballsiest things that Charlie
Murphy did was Charlie Murphy was famous
first of all,
for being the brother of a really
fucking famous comedian.
And second of all for being on the
greatest sketch comedy show,
the world's ever known and being a big
part of it.
He was huge on the Chappelle show.
Charlie Murphy stories or stories that
he would tell,
like the prince story.
Like,
dude,
he was famous for telling hilarious
stories and people would like look
forward to it.
He would be on the stage or on the
screen and you know,
just just waist up telling a story and
then you'd see like it be playing out
with Dave Chappelle being prince and all
the crazy shit that it would be a part
of those stories.
And then Charlie started doing stand up
after that.
So after that,
and you know,
there's some legendary bad sets that
he's had.
He had some bad sets like that were
captured on video where one of them we
did a college,
they're booing him and he went back and
got the check and tore it up in front of
them and threw it out to him left.
You know,
he's,
he took fucking crazy chances because
he's a famous open miker and you know as
well as I know that process cannot be
duplicated.
The process of becoming good at doing
standup,
going from an open miker to being like
a,
an established professional is a fucking
bloody grind and it's filled with dead
bodies.
Some people that just don't make it,
they don't make it.
It's rough.
It's,
it's like any kind of bootcamp,
but it lasts even longer than it's going
to high school,
you know?
Yeah,
like four years and then you graduate,
but some people don't graduate.
They get held back and killed,
killed by terrorists.
And along the way,
Charlie is famous so long this way he's
fucking famous for being hilarious and
he's just starting out or just starting
out and he's headlining.
Remember when we did that,
a maximum real men,
a comedy tour,
dude,
he had only been doing comedy like two
or three years,
you know,
and he's doing 45 minutes in front of
theaters.
Thousands of people balls,
man.
He's got balls.
But that's what it's like.
It's like being a famous,
open miker.
Well,
that's what it's like for these guys
that are plagiarists and then all of a
sudden they start trying to write their
own material.
It's like this dark man,
so dark place to be.
There's a guy named Freddy,
uh,
who,
Carerra,
uh,
he's going to be opening up for Joey
Diaz,
uh,
later this month in Reno,
seven to 25 and seven,
26.
He posted a video,
he sent me a video the other day.
Have you seen the heckler spartacus
kick?
What do you feel about this?
Because a lot of people actually got mad
at this video.
Uh,
and,
but then I think it makes complete sense
if you watched that guy.
Yeah.
If you haven't seen the video,
this dude is on stage.
This guy comes over to him and touches
him.
He says something to her,
it pushes them or touching them
physically.
And he says,
don't fucking touch me.
Get your fucking hands off me.
The guy leaves and it's a tiny ass
little crowd.
There's a very small amount of people
and some people apparently like this
heckler guy.
So the heckler guy,
um,
and this comic get into it again and the
comic says,
don't fucking come anywhere near.
It says like raids zone was given a
warning several times to not put his
hand.
So he goes running up to the stage in
full stride.
And this dude just front kicks right in
the chest.
Yeah.
300 style.
I guess the guys in front kick.
Good technique.
By the way,
this guy's named red zone,
I guess he's a local comic.
This,
this guy that has the aluminum foil on
his head.
He's a local comic that just one of
those guys that you know doesn't work.
It's not working out really for him and
he never gets off stage.
He always does is he won't get off stage
the whole time.
He had called
people in the audience,
so he's one of those guys that is like a
social retard that wants attention.
So he goes to these comedy clubs and
becomes a part of the show.
So as this guy's back in a way,
by the way,
I'm torn because I love the fact that
Vegas has a comedy scene and open mics
even though there's no one in it.
I'm like,
ah,
that's cool.
Vegas got a little funky little open
mics because vegas is a weird place.
Yeah.
Can you turn this up because it's.
Audio is great.
Just kind of making fun of me.
Says my room.
He sits down and some woman is like,
all right,
love your way.
She's trying to get some Dick Right?
Here it comes.
What I tell you
what telling you call an ambulance
should call an ambulance when the guy
goes down like that.
He never know because he could have hit
his head and he could die.
I mean,
I'm not exaggerating,
you know,
so I would say,
oh,
you're being melodramatic note.
When someone front kicks you in the
chest like that,
you fall back easily can hit your head
and it.
I didn't see if he hit his head or not.
We could watch it again.
You got way back again?
Fell off.
So it didn't protect them as unlimited.
What's not real?
What's that?
Jamie?
Let me see it and back it up.
Back it up so I can see it.
Oh yeah.
He could easily hit his head.
Well,
you know what?
We're playing one more time.
It his legs though.
He's balanced as you guys go unconscious
to legs like that.
See,
I felt back like that and it's kind of
like he was doing a pushup.
Know Brian,
you don't know what you're talking
about.
That guy got kicked really hard in the
chest.
He fell back.
He's lucky that his feet are planted.
Dairy's not unconscious,
but he definitely could have banged his
head,
so I would not.
I would not say that he's faking it in
any stretch of the imagination.
Does a hard kick to the chest and by the
way,
the kid is through the kick,
knows how to kick and like go,
go do it one more time.
Just take it to the kid.
The kid who threw the kick.
Just go.
Just go there to slow motion.
I don't want to say it.
I want to see it like this.
That's a guys kicked.
People before guaranteed.
He didn't even bother taking his hand
off of the mic stand.
Noticed that death.
Guys know how he knows how to kick.
He's got some martial arts experience.
One hundred percent or someone taught
them how to throw a nasty front kick and
he knows how to do it because the way he
timed it and the way you hit that guy,
he hit him fucking hard.
I'm torn because first of all,
that guy is the guy on the ground is
obviously a con.
You know,
he's annoying.
He's probably terrible.
If you're a comedian,
you got to work with this guy and he
gets in the way,
but you know,
does it mean that he should have been
kicked in the chest like that?
Man,
I don't know.
But the other thing is he was in full
stride to get in that guy's face and if
the guy didn't want to grapple with
them,
you get two options.
That guy ran right up to him.
Like,
you look at him,
he's,
he's walking like he's.
He got stopped by that kick.
He was going to get right to that guy.
Look,
he's in mid stride,
not slowing down at all.
He could have pushed that guy.
He could look.
He's reaching out to them.
Look,
fuck that guy.
That guy.
I see.
I,
you know what I mean?
I don't like the fact that he banged his
head and literally he could get really
badly hurt in a situation like that.
But
at the end,
the beginning of the video also,
the guy had already grabbed him like
he's like,
don't grab me.
And then the beginning of the video is
him,
like,
I'm warning,
do not come up here.
So it's,
there's,
yeah,
I,
I'm,
I'm for it.
I definitely think the guy's a cunt.
But the reality is the club should have
got rid of that dude.
You can't let somebody grab people like
that.
You can't.
Someone run up the stage like that.
They,
you know,
they probably can't afford security.
There's only five people in the
audience.
We're going to hire some guy was going
to eat up your profits to stand around
there looking big.
So it's fucked.
You know,
Greg Fitzsimmons gotten a scrap once it
stitches comedy Club in Boston where I
was,
I missed the show.
Fuck,
I wish I was there.
But uh,
some guy was in the audience,
some guy was heckling greg tool them.
And then the guy ran up onto the stage
and grab greg and they fucking scuffled
like they literally got into a
fistfight.
The bouncers came up,
dragged guy offstage.
Greg stood up,
brushed himself off and goes,
alright,
anybody else wants some of this?
And then went back with his act.
He was like,
who's next?
It was,
it was,
uh,
it was really funny.
Yeah.
The fights are interesting except that
easily at the comedy store anywhere on
sunset,
it's easily more like he's going to gun
like that.
There's been so many of those nights
there.
You've heard,
uh,
someone have a gun in the audience.
Well,
on a certain night.
Oh,
the Black Knight.
Yeah.
So going to say,
yeah,
that has happened.
It wasn't there.
A shots fired once when Tupac was at the
comedy store.
Yeah.
Well,
what are you who,
who would've figure who saw that coming?
I've got killed by gunfire.
Who had been shot twice.
Somehow another would be involved in
some sort of a shooting things that me,
this crazy story on my let you read it.
Is it about them hanging out at the
comedy store with Mitzi?
No.
Japanese boxer.
Twenty four burst into lawyers.
Lawyer's office cuts off the 42 year old
man's penis with a garden sheers.
Whoosh.
Flushes the Oregon down the toilet after
discovering wife's affair.
Wow.
Oh,
he carried out the horrifying attack in
Tokyo earlier this morning.
He punched the unnamed lawyer repeatedly
before severing his genitals,
flushed a peanutella toil,
and waited for the police.
The skilled boxers taught to have
carried out the attack after finding out
the Lord had been sleeping with his
wife.
Damn saying girl.
No you don't.
Well,
he has to blame the girl.
Yes,
but you can't blame a girl for this guy
coming in and cutting off that guy's
Dick.
No,
no,
no.
He should have.
I never understand why they go after the
guy.
You should go out the curl your wife.
Well,
Japanese guy might not even be a
different culture,
you know,
maybe in their culture.
You got to attack the man with garden
shears.
Yeah,
that's fucked.
Do you remember when there was a real
bad story where a lady did that to her
husband cut his dick off and threw it in
a garbage disposal?
Bobbitt and.
No,
no,
no.
She threw it.
She threw it out the window.
Um,
while she was driving her car and they
found it and stitch it back on this lady
through it in the garbage disposal.
And Sharon Osborne,
Ozzy's wife was on one of those dumb
chick shows and was mocking it,
laughing about how it must've looked
like spinning around in a circle.
You never heard that dude.
It's awful.
Play a jam because it's really awful
because imagine if there was a show like
a man's show and it's,
this is the guy network,
you know,
whatever.
And on that show,
a guy had cut his wife's clit off and
throw it in a garbage disposal,
you know,
Egyptian style,
they do that,
uh,
that,
that horrible genital mutilation they do
on a young lady's.
Imagine someone who was on TV marketing
that like,
imagine what the Luke Luke just spinning
around in circles.
This guy's life is ruined.
I don't know the circumstances.
I don't know why he filed the divorce.
I don't know what was going on between
them.
However,
I do think it's quite fabulous.
I mean,
I think it's quite fabulous.
Cool.
Wow,
that's awful.
Fuck men,
Joe,
fuck them.
It's awful that someone would say
something like that.
You know,
what is going on here?
Something else,
why she cut it off.
I mean,
it does depend on the reasons why does
it fuck her.
Poor Ozzie married to that monster.
That's a terrible thing to think.
Like why?
Why would anybody think that unless the
guy had done something horrible like
that to her and she got a hold of him,
you know,
like he cut her clit off and she waited
until he went to bed and cut his dick
off.
You know,
that's an eye for an eye and they're
both blind now,
but that's not what happened.
Whenever the fuck he did,
you know,
Jesus Christ.
The fact that she could mark that.
I don't know what my original point was.
What do you think are those explosions
in China?
Do you think that's just what they're
saying it is?
Or do you think that's like a secret
nuclear underground,
you know,
nuclear base that there.
Fuck you talking about nuclear.
Well,
it,
you know,
we recently found out that China,
supposedly it was,
it China that hack the Pentagon and it
just seems like,
you know,
a couple of weeks later now there's
nuclear size explosions in their cities.
There was a conspiracy theory.
China is enormous,
right?
Okay.
So you're saying China is.
If
it's like this fucking one block,
right?
Like we're attacking compton,
like China's an enormous spot and
China's a big industrial spot.
So there's constantly a bunch of shit
that can go wrong and blow up.
I mean,
that's just what happens when you're
building things.
You're using engines and fire and
gasoline compression and it easily.
It can be what they said.
A chemical plant blew up.
They blow up all the time when they blow
up,
it's God damn terrifying.
I've just never seen it that bad.
It looks like some of the new angles
know,
show some.
Uh,
I sent one of them.
I think this is the same one that I was
talking about where it literally goes,
there's three explosions.
The first one's like,
wow,
that's crazy.
They're saying like,
hey,
it looks like a gas station maybe blew
up.
Then the second one,
it's huge.
And it's like,
all right,
this is starting to look like a
transformers the movie.
And then the third one just like,
that's the end of rural explosion.
Uh,
and this,
a video that I think it's the right one
is literally,
it seems like it's across the street
almost and it's a great angle.
Well,
I've seen the one where the guys inside
the convenience store and the blast hits
him and the wall just knocks him back.
The windows knock him back and he looks
like he got fucked up.
I don't know what happened to the dude
in that picture,
but the blast from it.
Yeah.
This is it.
Now this is cool because the
conversation in it,
the people talking and it is awesome.
White People Canadian.
That sounds like Harland Williams.
Watch the second one.
Oh.
Oh my God.
That's not even the worst one.
Dangerous here.
The fire in the sky.
Yeah,
let's go.
It went from fun,
Fun Times.
Yeah.
Well that looks.
That looks exactly like what they said
in his.
Yeah.
I don't think that's any terrorist shit
that looks like a bomb blew up a
gigantic chemical factory at bomb blew
up.
I mean,
you know,
whatever.
An explosion.
Not a bomb,
but I mean,
same thing was just an explosion.
Have you seen the photos of the cars on
the right side of cdot?
There's cars that are parked there.
What is this sodium side?
Night on site might have been 70 times a
loud amount.
Oh yeah.
They only have rules in China.
They just,
it's a lot of chemicals that shouldn't
have been there,
but I think they're saying.
Oh,
that makes sense.
That was amazing though.
That was beautiful too.
It's fucked up,
but beautiful at the same time.
Like there's something cool about that.
Um,
if they can show us just the trail
destruction,
what it's done to buildings.
If you can find the one where the guys
inside the store and the blast hits him
because that one is insane.
What are you doing over there?
Prime a tune out on me.
Oh,
it's just finding a new video,
uh,
that uh,
have a house from erosion falling into
the ocean that I wanted to show you.
I was one of those stilt houses.
Uh,
it's.
Yeah,
I guess it's like in poor countries they
don't have the right foundations and a
lot of their houses.
So they just fall into the ocean in
Malibu.
Yeah,
exactly.
Shit happens there.
They have all these crazy walls and
stuff they build up in Malborough.
Here's the security camera footage.
This is the guy right in front of the
door,
like wash this.
Boom Dude,
you got jacked.
I mean,
who knows what happened to that dude,
but when he gets knocked back he is
fucked because everything exploded.
Like,
look how it goes back.
He's looking at his phone to look
homeboys looking at his fucking phone.
He's standing by the window.
Watch that again.
Look,
this bitch hasn't even text me back,
man.
I mean he literally didn't even see it
coming.
Now it looks like a hits his head first
and goes,
look,
duck heck.
And then the whole house or the side
just follows on them.
I like your bad accent.
So that's the most harsh.
Ha ha ha.
Okay Dad.
But there was a,
um,
a guy who set up an explosion in his
house.
He,
uh,
left the gas on and set like some sort
of a timer and set some sort of a device
to ignite it.
And it blew the house up,
he was doing it for an insurance scam
and he went to jail for murder because
you wind up killing his neighbor.
Remember that?
Yeah.
He,
um,
see if you find that story,
but the fucking damage that just got
done from a line inside a person's house
and it makes you think it's crazy that
you're,
you could just do that.
Like if you were a nut and you just
wanted to turn your gas on and sit
there,
look,
look at this as leveled.
Wow.
Fucking two houses on this block.
And this was all done with gas.
This makes sure that this is the right
one because there have been like
explosions that were accidental that did
happen,
that caused some pretty significant with
murder in this.
Yeah,
that's it.
Wow.
Yeah,
it's Indiana too.
That's,
that's where it happened at famous
video.
The house blowing up at that came out a
couple of years ago where,
uh,
you,
you know what I'm talking about Jamie,
that Nice house where the helicopter
going around the house.
Yeah.
It was a fire.
There was a fire going on,
right?
And then the house exploded in the
middle of this.
So this guy just left the fucking gas on
and then said we're going to make some
money,
but just look at these three.
They get caught at the guy on the far
right.
You almost don't blame him.
Right whenever that chicken in the
middle says,
I'll do.
How hard was that guy's life?
The guy in the far right with the
glasses.
How hard must have his life had been his
life.
We're looking at this guy who looks like
William h macy,
um,
had sex with
somebody to the left and somebody to the
right.
Now it looks like William h macy and
vandelay Silva is,
knows postsurgery with a one wonky I
poor bastard.
Look at them.
They,
I think was just a mess.
That guys just lived a life of misery,
misery,
and very little love.
It's just got this feel about them.
And so they decided they were going to
make some money from a insurance money
when you have a sideways.
I like that.
Do you actually have better vision than
print it from.
You know what I mean?
Like maybe you have a way better vision
that way.
I don't think so.
I think actually fucks up your straight
vision because you're always getting a
little bit of this side stuff in there.
It's probably.
I mean it's probably fucks with your.
Your straight ahead vision.
Hmm.
Yeah,
I guess it would.
but if you can move them independently,
like some sort of a chameleon.
We're supposed to have eyes in front of
us.
Right?
The idea being that's one of the main
indicators that were predators.
We have eyes in front of us because
we're looking forward to killing things
were not looking on our sides like deer,
like the reason why deer have on the
side of their head because they're
terrified.
They have to look at what's over there.
What's over there.
You know they have to.
They can look.
They can be going sideways like this.
Their head can be totally facing
sideways,
can look right at you.
We can't do that because we don't need
to worry as much about getting flanked.
We're usually the pursuers and not to
pursue.
He's speaking of pursuers and not
pursuing.
He's running with the Bulls was
particularly successful this season.
The bowls scored seven kills.
Wow.
Yeah,
that's the highest risk is a big one.
It's a big year for them.
They're very excited.
They,
uh,
they went back to the,
to the slaughterhouse and we're pretty
pumped before they got killed because
they,
I think they killed them.
I mean,
I don't,
I don't know what happens with the
bowls.
What happens with the Bulls and they run
with the Bulls.
It's not like bullfighting,
right?
I think they just fight and fight and
fight and fight.
We're going to have to talk.
We can't just only look at laptops here
because otherwise I'm only talking to
you.
I'm listening and interacting.
Sending new links.
Oh,
well let's just talk about the bowl
thing because it's so ridiculous.
Pull that up.
Champion,
because it's incredible.
It's seven people died.
Why the fuck do they do it?
I just,
that's what I guess it's a thrill.
Is that the idea behind it?
It's a tradition.
It's,
you know what I mean?
So slavery.
Should we go back to that tradition?
The inquisition was kind of a tradition.
Slavery still exists,
you just get paid for it.
10 people died at 10 now.
Three more for this weekend.
Oh,
it's been this really good week.
The bowls are and pull it up,
put,
put some shit up.
Look at this for more gored to death
across Spain as surge and bull run
casualties continue.
I hope the bowls are just getting
smarter.
Look how fucking big they are and look
how many people there are.
That's what's fucked up.
There's way too many people to get out
of the way.
You just can't get out of the way.
She got these bowls and they're real
bowls with full on horns and these real
bowls are just running into these packed
avenues of people and just knowing them
over and killing them fucking
ridiculously stupid has got to be one of
the dumbest ways to die.
I wrote this article about this long
time ago joking around about how dumb it
was and this guy got really mad at me.
It's like my teacher,
my professor did that and it's all about
appreciating the culture and like,
how come you can't just go to the
country?
Why do you have to run from a fucking
animal to appreciate the culture?
Did you say thing burt was doing this
week and I've seen it before.
They chase cheese down a hill and these
guys run down a hill and get hurt.
Similar done thing.
Well,
you don't have to chase the cheese
cheeses and trying to kill you.
This is totally different.
I mean this is so gross,
man.
Spain's economic crisis is forced to
sharp drop in the number of bull fights
in the country with about 300 fewer bull
fights scheduled for this year as
compared to the years before the crisis.
Yet the number of ranchers who are
raising fighting bowles has stayed the
same.
The only way out for these ranchers
would be in the festivals and these
municipalities so suggests that many of
the bowls that would have been destined
for bull fights or instead running along
the streets of the country.
That's fucking crazy because those are
really big bowls and they're really
ferocious and they come from a long line
of Bulls that have been almost bred for
that shit.
They're doing it in the United States
now.
I'm pretty sure Kevin,
like little set of bull runs and you can
go run through these things right there.
It says right there,
these are bulls with more power,
more capacity to charge a said Lorca,
whoever that is,
a of the bowls being used for small town
bull runs.
He said that an encounter with one of
those,
one of these would likely do more harm
than the bowls of previous years.
Obviously you've got fucking 11 deaths
this year.
What a cluster fuck.
And in the US they're using them to
clean out homeless populations by
putting them downtown at night.
Can you imagine if they did that though?
They had like a bull run every once a
week and they just play almost like a
home was like,
oh,
I'll get this bolt.
Well,
the real problem is not the fatality.
It's the homeless people that survive.
It's going to be even worse.
You're going to take care of those
people for the rest of their lives.
This is the whole thing is fucking
gross.
The whole thing is completely ridiculous
as well as the bull fights are fucking
ridiculous too,
because first of all there,
you're not really fighting that bowl,
right?
You're stabbing it with spears and
you're running around.
Other people get to stab it and some of
the spears are.
They have a poisoning them man gored to
death filming bull run in Spain on
mobile phone.
World store.
Yeah.
There's a great video of a guy getting
one up the asshole.
I don't mean great really,
but I mean like,
whoa.
You seen that one where the guy gets the
horns right up the ass hole.
So horrible.
It's like Jesus Christ.
He got his fingers torn open.
His rectum was torn apart.
Rectum nearly killed him,
right?
Yeah.
I think that was when the first animated
gifs I ever saw and I was like,
what?
What's going on?
That horns going into twentieths,
but you just from it loading so slow.
It's ugly.
Dude.
These people know that this guy's got
one in the face.
Let's go through all these.
Let's go through all these please,
please visit.
Visit the image.
Um,
let's get the first one again.
Closing on that first one because it
seems like it's going right through his
cheek.
Is that what's happening here?
Yes,
it is.
Look,
it's right through his cheek.
Look at the fucking impact through that.
Oh my God.
It's going through his eyeball.
Look at that.
Brian will get it through his eyeball.
Now,
as a confirmed member of team people,
I cannot say that I'm happy about this,
but there are too many people in the
four or five and I think the only way to
stop that is to kill off a few retards.
You don't want to kill off the good
people and they're not saying this guy
was retarded,
but his occupation most certainly was.
You know,
maybe just as a hard way out,
man.
It's hard to get out.
Get off that photo.
He was a bull fighter and his family's
bullfighters like,
don't be a pussy.
Me.
Whoa.
Oh,
this is a different guy.
Get one of the face is a different one
though.
It's a different dude,
right?
Isn't it?
Is it because the horns look different
because the other one,
the horns were black and this one
they're white.
See the tips are white and black and
there's a blue thing sticking out of his
net.
Go to the first one again.
Yeah.
Maybe it's the same guy.
Might be the same guy.
It might just be the resolution.
Picked up the actual cover color of the
forms better.
That's dark shit,
dude.
Having horns go through your fucking eye
and that's his eyeball.
Blown out like that.
No shoe either.
Lost a shoe.
Poor bastard.
I got something better than that.
That will clean the palate of seeing all
that disgusting shit.
Have you seen that little Asian girl
that can hypnotize animals?
She puts.
She puts like seven different animals
on,
on this table and at first it's like a
lizard and she's like.
And then the lizard just passes out and
then she goes to a dog and that dog
passes out and then a frog.
See this?
This involves two things for you.
It involves Asian girls.
Now I'm talking about,
like I said,
the baby might not be real.
No,
this is on a game show.
Oh.
And it's definitely real.
Right?
Well,
I mean it's,
it's pretty interesting because at one
point she's like,
she has like a certain time limit to go
down all these animals.
At one point the dog wakes up was like,
what the fuck happened?
I just sent you.
It is amazing though.
And
like it would make sense.
Like how,
how can someone hypnotize a dog?
Okay.
So here's the girl.
That's what does the sky ladder.
What is all that?
I don't know.
The Chinese Americans,
the dog lays down
and then the guys pretending that he's
falling asleep too.
Yeah.
And so the dog just.
She just hear this.
That's a puppy that's lying down.
Yeah.
Okay.
So the dog
is just good at laying down like that
cute lizard though.
[inaudible] ad lizards awake by the way.
She flips the lizard upside down and
then just starts rubbing the belly and.
Okay,
well do you know that that's actually a
way to put lizards asleep.
That's why you do that with crocodiles
and alligators.
You put them on their back and rub their
belly and they pass out and I didn't
fight.
It's kind of cool.
I like seeing her do this,
especially.
Sure that that's the case with lizards
to that.
Some of them,
when you lay on their back,
it's the way they're designed.
Like I think that's what I read about a
sharks as well.
Like sharks,
if you flip them upside down,
there's something about the way they're
designed,
the way they're designed by the big guy
upstairs that uh,
when you do that to them for whatever
reason,
they can't stay conscious.
It makes sense.
And there's something about structure to
like push them if they get stopped,
like they can't move or something.
Do you know I'm talking about what do
you mean they can't move like a few
reinserted shark in the water.
You kind of have to give it a little
scoot or it won't be able to swim.
I don't know.
That kind of makes sense because they're
always constantly in motion in some ways
that make sense.
Like they might not know what to do.
[inaudible] I'm bill Nye.
Factors entered my brain.
That's all I was asking.
That might be true.
So I'm not impressed with the lizard.
Is fraud figured out that it was on its
back?
You flipped back over.
Why is it so interesting too?
Because she,
she does it to a bunny rabbit.
She does it to a bird.
She does it to a dog and she covered the
birds face.
That's what you do if you cover the face
with a,
like a blanket like that.
The verge freaks out and just lays there
like I was just trying to get off of the
discussing bowl.
Yeah.
This is stupid as fuck.
I can't believe you made me watch.
How about the truck crashing into a
highway sign.
This truck was driving down the highway
and somebody dashboard cam catches the
truck.
Hit one of those overpass signs that say
like up ahead I five and stuff like
that.
Uh,
it was too tall for the overpass and
it's very scary.
Yeah,
it's,
it's a very scary video that to uh,
why is it scary?
I don't know.
It just,
it hit.
It's a car accident.
Scary.
Like if you were behind that and here it
is,
boom.
And that's this,
you know,
didn't even tip over.
That's fucking impressive as shit.
So what did they had to load up and
they've forgotten the loader was up and
they were driving.
Yeah.
It's kind of like a dump truck thing and
it was up and they didn't know.
I was just like,
I worked for you,
you know,
like you fucking dope.
You can even just look before you drive
on the highway,
you fucking idiot.
Jesus Christ.
That's probably a big problem with
running a company though,
right?
That you have idiots.
Yeah,
absolutely.
If you have people drive and shit around
for you like rocks,
you've got a bucket of rocks in the back
of that thing or you know,
tractor trailer full of rocks,
whatever.
And you have these dummies that are
working for you dumping these rocks off.
And then we dropped it off with Dr.
I think we should lower that thing.
The time
I do it all the time.
He just takes on the highway like that
destroys that sign.
Flux.
You got to pay for that sign too.
Yeah.
I'm sure that company has to pay for the
sign.
We used to have employees because they
used to be a manager for a long time.
You still have two gentlemen,
one of those people out there with an
actual job,
but we them Brian being your boss.
The worst though is that when you hire
somebody and then you realized,
Oh shit,
that was such a mistake and you can't.
It's really hard just to fire somebody.
You have to go through like certain,
you know,
laws and stuff like that.
Yeah.
They're were like,
especially the government jobs,
government jobs is real hard,
you know,
we learned that.
Um,
well I kind of always knew it,
but we really learned that when it came
to Nevada and referees and judges for
mma really hard to get a judge fired
really hard.
Like they can,
they could prove to be absolutely
totally incompetent.
But it's like working at the DMV,
like once you have one of those
government jobs,
like you're a government official,
official officiator a someone who judges
fights like that.
You might as well have a job working for
any other government agency.
Like it's super difficult to fire you.
Especially with something like like
fights,
because if you watch a fight and you've
seen a bunch of fights,
you kind of know who won,
who doesn't want,
but it's subjective.
Like you might decide that one person
one,
but Jamie might decide that another
person one,
and there are fights where people
adamantly like argue one way or the
other,
but there's some that are just
undeniable.
And when you get those undeniable ones,
they're like,
what the fuck were you watching?
How did this guy win?
And those undeniable ones,
you got to step in,
you've got to fire people.
And they can't.
They just can't.
You can't because it's a subjective.
All this person has to do is say,
Hey,
I,
I officiated 100,
a hundred different fighting shows and I
was a never criticized for any of those.
Most time you don't get criticized.
It has to be completely egregious before
you get criticized.
But it's fucking hard as shit to fire
one of those people,
they just,
uh,
they dig their heels in,
especially if they're a part of a
minority group,
you know,
then they can get people behind them.
And you know,
I've,
I've literally heard that conversation
before,
like someone say,
well there'd be two different problems,
one of firing someone is hard and then
firing someone who might be black or a
woman they go is even harder.
And I went,
you got to be kidding me.
Like when you,
if you fire a judge,
it's not based on their competency,
like some of it has to be considered
whether or not they're black or a woman.
And he goes,
absolutely,
absolutely.
He goes,
you might as well be,
like I said,
firing someone who works for any other
government,
government agency,
you have to treat it like that.
Whereas like you would just like,
it was like roast battle.
Okay,
let's put roast battle and contexts,
which is an awesome show that people
judge and it's very rare that anybody
disagrees on who won the roast battle.
But it can get close,
right?
It can get closed.
It gets weird.
Sometimes people are biased,
right?
Yeah.
They get biased or they're just doing it
because they want to see another round,
like the scoring part.
Not really even real.
I know sometimes that does happen,
that definitely happens,
but when a guy gets trounced,
it's pretty obvious.
Right?
But in fights guys have gotten trounced
and still lost or still one,
I think I got his ass kicked.
It's still want a decision that has
happened.
Not just once a gang of times.
There was a lady that was doing that in
Vegas and she was responsible for like
two or three really bad decisions.
One of them was packy out,
um,
uh,
Timothy Bradley and uh,
there was another,
there was another big fight.
I forget what the other one was.
Her.
She had a,
like an initial name,
like a tj something or another
instrument.
Tired Blonde.
Oh,
remember?
I remember what she looked like,
but I remember people saying that it
very well could have been that she was
paid off by people.
Yeah.
That was the one she,
I think she's retired.
She just took so much heat because
people can gamble on those fights.
Especially a packing.
I'll fight.
You're talking about millions of dollars
being exchanged.
Millions.
I mean,
how many fucking people bet on a pack?
I'll fight.
That gets pretty nutty,
so who knows who came up to that lady
and told her look like a fucking draw.
It was a close.
It's close,
right?
It's cold sweat.
It's draw.
So judges in like an appointed elected
or not elected or appointed official.
Yeah.
Can't be replaced.
It's very hard in a system be changed at
all.
Like the way the very hard is happening.
No,
very hard to change it.
You know,
he's got a great judging idea.
Is Anthony Hard?
Donk who used to fight for the UFC now
he's a.
I'm a trainer.
Transit Dynamics in Santa Monica.
Trains a lot of UFC fighters but he's
out a great idea for scoring system and
his idea first coding scoring system is
totally different than the one they have
now.
What they have now is it's called the 10
point must system and that's what boxing
uses.
So everybody starts out with 10 points,
but if say you knocked me down,
then you get like you have 10 and I have
eight because you're knocked me down.
If I lost the round and it's nine,
but 10 nines can guide and go either
way,
like 10,
nine,
like I might think you won ten nine,
but somebody else might think Brian,
1:10,
nine.
It says real subjective.
But once I got,
gets knocked down,
it's pretty universally 10,
eight.
Unless a guy was dominating the whole
round and then got knocked down,
then it will be nine,
nine,
then it'd be a draw.
But that's,
that's usually not what happens.
Usually when the guy gets knocked down,
it's tonight would hard dog is saying is
that,
that doesn't make any sense.
And that all of the scores,
I know his name,
but he's from Holland.
Um,
all of the scores for all the techniques
should count.
So like the first round might be six.
You might have six and he might have to
because like you beat him up.
He did a bunch of things to um,
and all those things count as points.
And then the next round it might be a,
you have four and you have three.
So even though there's two rounds in the
books and you won the first round and he
wanted the second round,
he only won the second round by one
point.
Whereas you were on the first round by a
bunch of points because you're counting
up all the different things that you did
during that
round.
So it's accumulative.
So instead of this 10,
nine system where you can have two,
10,
nine rounds,
but 1:10,
nine round,
you totally kick Jamie's ass.
But the next 10,
nine,
nine round,
Jamie barely,
barely squeaks by you.
Barely.
Almost like a roast battle situation
where you give it to him because he came
back from that first round and then
you're even going into this third and
final round,
but you're not even.
The reality is you fucked him up way
more than he fucked you up.
And he's got a really good point with
that because the idea of having to 10,
nine rounds and one of them is just
vastly different.
There's 10,
nine rounds where a guy literally does
nothing to the other guy,
just gets his ass kicked all over the
place and just survives,
still loses 10,
nine and then in the other one,
two guys go toe to toe and it's almost
in site indiscernible who won and that's
also ten nine stupid.
He's totally right.
And what his idea is a score shouldn't
be like 49,
48,
49,
47 and the third Georgia judge scores
it.
He's like,
it really should be a number like 30 and
12 or 37 and six or 45 and 13 or 45 and
40 like where there's a big numbers.
If the fight has a lot of action,
like a lot of Schutz shit's going on.
It's not just ten nine.
There's head kicks and take downs and or
there could be a 10,
nine round where both guys like Anderson
Silva versus tonsillitis.
Here's a perfect example.
Anderson Silva fought tirelessly and
neither one exchanged.
Neither one did anything.
There was many times in that fight it
was boring as fuck because Anderson's
counter striker and Talus is a Jujitsu
fighter.
So Anderson knew that he could pick them
apart on the outside and not do much and
Talis knew that if he ran at Anderson
it's like running into a meat chipper or
a wood chipper.
So he had to figure out which way to
which way to to to play the fight out.
So there was very little action.
It was a really boring fight.
Well that's still 10,
nine,
10,
nine round.
I mean that these are 10,
nine rounds.
How could that be a 10,
nine round when you come up with
something fucking completely crazy and
chaotic.
That could also be a 10,
nine round like shogun versus Dan
Henderson.
They beat the fuck out of each other and
that could also be a 10,
nine round,
you know,
that's crazy.
It doesn't make any sense.
The fights where there's a lot of
action,
the score should be higher and I think
that would also.
It would also show like how exciting
fighters are,
you know,
you could say like Michael Jordan scored
50 points playing for the Chicago Bulls
and everybody's like,
Holy Shit,
Jordan here.
Jordan scored 50 last night.
We'll have Ronda rousey flights a batch
Kohala again and beat the fucking shit
out of her for the first round,
but somehow or another batch makes it
into the second round and you look at
the score.
Her score for the first round was a
hundred and 62 co.
Hey,
I had one.
You know like if you see sometHing like
that,
like that's like holy shit.
I actually think it makes it better.
How would you say you do it though?
Would you just break the round up into
quarters and each each quarter you get
like 10 points or.
No,
you,
you would have to be just lIke scoring
and basketball and have to be the
techniques that land.
So like say if you and jamie are
fighting and you hit him with a like
five leg kicks in a row,
you'd have to.
You'd have to figure out a way to
quantify those leg kicks.
Like what is worth more is a leg kick
worth two points and a jab worth one
point is a right hand that rocks you
worth five points and one that grazes
off you worth one point.
You'd have to figure out,
and it have to be at least partially
subjective because the real quiet,
like the real undeniable measurable
thing and a fight is the knockout.
In the submission.
The tko even is problematic because
there's fights there stopped.
We're like,
ah,
just the guy was fucking that guy up,
but I would have liked to see the guy
had a chance to survive and then there's
other referees were the guy could get
fucked up way worse,
and the referee,
that's a go on.
The guy winds up winning the fight.
Frankie edgar versus gray maynard,
one or two and three.
The first time they fought edgar beaten
by decision.
The second time they fought,
edgar almost knocked him out or a gray.
Maynard almost knocked first fight gray.
Maynard won a decision.
Second fight.
I'm gray,
almost knocked him out and then frankie
wound up making it to the end and it was
a draw.
And then the third fight,
gray almost knocked him out again in the
first round and frankie wound up
knocking him out later in the fight.
So in fights like that,
like a worse referee would have called
that fight in the first round and gray
maynard would have knocked them out and
won the title.
So it's one of those weird things where
you just got to.
There's a certain amount of subjective
decision making that's going to be
involved in fights.
But I think if the score was based on
the actual damage that was done,
he'd have to figure out what it's worth
though.
What's it worth to have someone's back,
what's it worth to mount someone.
But I don't think it's a bad thing to
figure that out.
I think it would be worth a lot for the
sport to get outside of this boxing
system isn't damaged subjective to the
yes.
Because totally one hit from,
you know what I mean?
You could hit me and brian both the same
way and it's going to hurt us a
different way and counted the same way
at all.
And some guys can take a shot away
better than other guys can In the same
shot.
Like you hit Mark Hunt with it and he'll
eat it and smile at you.
And same shot,
you hit another guy with it and his leg
go out and he,
he,
he's done.
Yeah.
It's hard to say,
but it's,
you,
you base it on how hard her hurt the guy
was,
what the impact was,
how clear the impact was.
There'd be a lot of factors.
There's a lot of factors that would play
in when you would deal with,
uh,
with scoring a fight.
But it's got.
It's got to be way better than what
they're doing right now.
What they're doing right now.
It's just terrible.
There's just,
there's so many.
Like I'm a ramsey and a gym.
the gym he hates when I say new gym,
I always fuck it up.
Ramsey nejame,
he got robbed in his last fight.
The gentleman who he fought,
I forget his name,
doesn't matter,
but ran.
I thought ramsey,
clearly one of the fight and they gave
it to the other dude.
And I was like,
tHat's bullshit.
That guy did what he was supposed to do.
won the fight.
And he didn't win the fight.
Why?
Because the judges were incompetent.
Everybody ringside.
That was with me.
Quayside.
Joe silva.
Sean shelby rather,
we're looking at each other,
shaking her head like,
what the fuck?
you know?
Dana was shaking his head.
A lot of people shaking their head like,
this is ridiculous.
How the fuck did this happen?
This is terrible.
This is god damn terrible decision.
There was another one recently where
I'm.
Dana was on record talking about it.
There was a.
It was a big.
Oh,
Michael Johnson.
Michael johnson and biennials are huge.
A lot of people thought Michael Johnson
won that fight.
I thought it was a little closer than a
lot of people were thinking.
I thought she did a lot of stuff that
for whatever reason people weren't
giving them credit for,
but I still thought johnson,
it was real fucking clothes thought.
Johnson probably got the nod.
I'd have to go over it again with the
sound off maybe and really trying to
analyze it point by point,
but a lot of people were pissed.
A lot of people watched it live.
We're really pissed and it'd be cool in
the future at the technology would be
there to be able to act accurately,
find out how strong each punch is and
like every,
you know,
it's almost like you could wear a
bracelet that can detect that almost in
the future or something like really
detect the amount of damage you
sustained.
So if video games right?
So like one big punch is Worth like
three or four week ones,
you know,
like being,
being,
being or boom.
Right.
Yeah.
That's all done by pressure and
vibration of the actual hit.
I think also the idea of having three
judges is not necessarily.
I think there's more than three judges.
Mind,
nose.
I think they would probably.
If you get five experts and it's not
hard to find judges,
you could go on the underground,
you go out and mixed martial arts.com
and find a hundred people there are way
more competent than anybody's working
today or as competent as the best people
working today.
I really stand by that.
I really think fans like really big time
fans that are.
They probably know more about mma than
most referees are.
Most judges rather because most judges,
I think there's a good percentage of
them that really don't even give a fuck
about the sport.
That's just they're doing it.
Some of them are fans of the sport,
but some of them definitely aren't.
So I think that having more judges would
be good and I think another thing would
be good is allowing the people at home
devote,
allowing them to vote online.
So maybe draws would be broken up by the
online score.
Absolutely.
It's not a bad idea.
They should totally be more interactive.
Why not?
The technology's there and that's.
That would make more sense to know how
dope that would be if they went,
okay,
we're going to go to the internet,
you know,
it's a draw so we're going to go to the
internet or just have a score based on
internet and a score based on reality.
So the internet score I won by a
landslide,
but gets really biased that way.
Of course it does.
It's part of the funding.
All star games get ruined in some sports
because of those fans.
Can vote stuff like baseball,
the whole american thing to do one team
this year.
You're right.
I take ticket back,
take it back.
Plus some fighters that people hate.
Everybody hates,
you know,
they like to hate them to goes to cocky.
Like there's a lot of people that would
like try to like vote against conor
mcgregor just because he's doing too
well.
I'm hoping that guy falls on his face.
If you're up in the third round in a
scenario where you can score that way in
your app,
like I don't know,
35 to 15 and you kind of just stopped
because you're up.
Right?
Like what,
how do you prevent that?
Or can you not?
Or is that just a project to deal with?
I mean that's just part of the game,
but the guy who's down,
it's his job to go after you now and try
to score and win.
Try to knock you out.
Try to stop the fight.
And there's some.
Sometimes we're a guy,
we all know this,
where guys going into the third round
and he got his ass kicked the first two
rounds in this corner says,
you've got to stop him.
You got to finish this fight.
He knows it.
He knows and the other guy knows it.
If he's,
if someone is clearly one,
two rounds in a row,
all you have to do is fucking dance
around in that third round.
Guys have done that before and it wound
up fucking them over.
True.
I don't know.
I think the system sucks.
The system is terrible but hard.
Onx ideas the best I've ever heard.
Doc hamilton who's a very good judge and
uh,
a long time martial arts practitioner,
he had a good system and his system was
a half point system.
His system was instead of 10 points,
you use half points too.
So like in cases where it's like real
close,
he could say,
well that guy won,
but he only won by half a point or he
won by a point where it's really clear
or he won by two points if he's really
got his ass kicked.
Like utilize the point system and make
it a bit more obvious that there was a
gap and that'll accumulative that we'll
uh,
that'll add up towards the end of a
third round.
You would be able to add that like,
well the first round he won by half a
point,
but the second round he won by two
points and then we'll all like,
it would show up better.
I just think the 10 point system as they
use it right now,
really lame and it comes from boxing,
just not a good system for mma.
It's a good system for boxing because
boxing is pretty much boxing and mma has
so many different kinds of scoring that
you could be on the ground and hadn't
been choked out the whole entire round.
And that has to mean something.
Yeah.
And it's also like,
who decides?
Like if you say,
if you beat a guy upstanding you,
you beat them up for like the first
minute,
hit him with a ton of punches,
but then it takes you down and gets on
top of you for four minutes but doesn't
do anything,
hits you with like a few pitty pat
punches,
but most of the time you defend
yourself.
A lot of times people will think that
that guy who was on the bottom getting
hit with a pitty pat punches by the guy
was on top of them,
lost the round.
Even though he beat the shit out of that
guy for the first minute.
Like he did way more damage that first
minute.
That guy's cut.
He's beat up his eyes swelling.
He got hit with bombs,
but he survived enough to get the take
down and then because he was on top for
more people would give him that round.
So it's goofy as fuck,
man.
It's really hard to figure out how to do
a better job of scoring it.
But I think the doc has the best idea
I've ever heard and I'm going to have
him on the podcast someday,
someday,
soon because he's out here.
He's out near woodland hills,
so I'm going to have him on soon and
have them talk about it and talk about
training and stuff like that too.
But I think his,
his system is way better.
Here's something I wanted to bring up
because it's pretty fucking crazy.
Um,
there was a new study that was out in a
reset.
Me,
you know,
Amber Lyons company.
She,
by the way,
it's become a complete drawing around
it.
Serious.
She's a total.
No,
just kidding,
kidding.
I mean that in the nicest way.
Amber common.
She's a calling.
He's got the shit.
She's become like a complete psychedelic
head.
She just,
all she does,
she's just traveled around the world
doing psychedelics.
But she wrote this,
she's got this new website,
it's called reset.me
obviously to a sort of signify the,
the profound effects of psychedelics.
And that's the,
uh,
the name of the website and what many
people think that psychedelics do.
And so this guy,
professor david nutt,
had this,
uh,
that's his name too,
not as funny as hard dog,
but it's pretty close.
Both guys three,
we had a three day conference.
It's called breaking convention that's
held in london and basically what
they're saying,
it's to explore the benefits of
psychedelics,
but they're saying this psilocybin
switches off part of the brain that
causes depression,
which is insane.
That's,
uh,
that's amazing.
Like go to that story.
Um,
so,
you know,
there's all these problems that they
have with trying to legalize different
things that are beneficial,
like legalized for soldiers with ptsd,
but they found a lot of different drugs
that can help people that have been
through traumatic situations.
Psilocybin is one of them.
Mtma is a big one.
Mtma apparently has profound effects
where people have seen horrific things
and profound in the fact that it lets
them change their perspective on it and
literally changed their memory,
changed what it beans to them to have
had this experience and allows
forgiveness in a way that's really
unprecedented.
So,
um,
this guy,
professor nut,
it's a really interesting article.
There's a lot of different talk about
psychedelics in it,
but about,
uh,
the potential for drugs like psilocybin
lsd and a,
and cannabis too,
and that he's talking about how because
these drugs are illegal,
uh,
patients are suffering,
committing suicide because they're not
getting treated for their depressions as
pain or their pain rather.
It's interesting because I think more
and more as time's going on,
you're seeing these things become
mainstream.
These subjects become mainstream.
The John Hopkins psilocybin study,
there's been quite a few different
studies that have come out that have
shown the benefits of a lot of different
drugs to dealing with things that are
conventionally.
What do they give you for depression?
They give you an ssri or they give you
something else,
but this is a completely different
effect and that's actually what ari
said.
Arias said that psilocybin was what
really helped his depression,
helped it in a big way.
It's interesting.
When I was in toronto,
I allegedly maybe have eight,
some shrooms both nights.
I was there because it illegal to say
you hate shrooms and I,
I don't know.
Nowadays they,
they check your twitter when you're
going through the airport wides.
Yeah.
Every time I go travel now me and tony
both get put into a room and they check
your twitter to see like,
where are you working tonight?
Huh?
Oh,
okay.
Here we go.
Tony uncle tony actually got caught.
Allegedly what?
Um,
because I think they recently passed
this law where you don't have to do this
anymore,
but when you work in Canada as a
comedian you have to get a work permit
and that causes the place.
But if it's like a really small little
show,
it's like a lot of places like,
ah,
just,
you know,
you're here on vacation or whatever.
And I think who said that?
The people that are booking the shell.
Yeah,
I can't do that.
We found this out.
This is like early on eddie bravo to
that too.
Yeah.
And so,
uh,
but tony said that they,
just went on his twitter page and just
as like where,
where are you at?
And they grounded him and made him fly
back.
Should've told me those number.
Twitter was retarded.
No,
they just googled his name.
Oh,
well.
Uh,
so that's one thing that's good about
having a fake last name.
Um,
but yeah,
what we're talking about right before
that,
mushrooms,
mushrooms.
This was the first time where I actually
never,
I didn't eat to try to trip hard.
I was just like,
you know what,
I'm going to take a little bit while I'm
at this bar.
And so it was just enough that I
immediately felt insane amounts of
happiness and I wasn't seeing anything
or,
or like it wasn't like,
like a trippy experience.
Uh,
but uh,
I know a lot of people that do that
thing where you eat a little bit of
mushrooms every day.
Have you heard about that?
And I wonder if that has something to
that because that could be almost like a
imagine being prescribed like a happy
pill every day and it was just ground up
mushrooms,
but it was just a smaller amount a where
you're not seeing anything but you still
feel happy because that's how I felt and
it caused me to eat more when I was
like,
oh,
this is great mushroom.
So,
but then I got out of that just
happiness and then I start tripping and
seeing things.
But the small amount that I originally
eight made me feel really happy.
I was bouncing off the walls.
That's it.
Common thing that people do,
they microdose and they'd take it all
day.
Yeah.
That's real common.
People do that and it definitely has an
interesting effect.
I've small doses before and it makes you
just feel relaxed.
It also makes the things that you
thought were super important seems so
silly.
Like things that were bothering you and
you're like,
who cares?
Like whatever.
Like you feel like if someone was mad at
you and like,
oh as that person mad at me to take a
little micro dose of mushrooms and
you're like,
I feel almost feel bad for them being
mad at me,
you know,
like people talking shit about you.
Whereas it would hurt your feelings.
You take a little mushrooms,
you're like,
feel bad for them.
Like this person is lashing out in this
ridiculous way.
Mushrooms are beautiful man.
They're so important.
So gross that they're illegal.
It's so bizarre that after all these
different years,
all these different studies,
there's never been one that's shown that
it kills people.
Never been one that's shown that it
causes you to lose your brain or even
get diarrhea.
I mean,
there's just nothing.
There's no reason why it should be
illegal.
There's no like glaring health issue and
yet still you could go to jail as much
as you would go to jail if yet had.
Probably more so than heroin isn't.
Heroin is scheduled today.
We've gone over this before like
marijuana and mushrooms.
The schedule ones like a lot of the
schedule ones are like super beneficial
and they're the most illegal.
If you look at the schedule one versus
scheduled to chart,
I think scheduled to his cocaine because
they have medical cocaine.
It's like schedule.
The idea of scheduled one is no medical,
no known medical use and to have
marijuana and mill psilocybin to have
the most beneficial plants of all time
in the no known medical use category
just shows how corrupt these criminals
are because that's just a lie.
Like anybody could go to them with a
series of links,
like I can email them to tell me who it
is.
It's the head of the drug czar guy.
I'll email you just a gang of links.
You click on those links and then tell
me if you think it's still scheduled one
after it's over and if you do think that
you're a crook.
I think the only difference between like
a cocaine or psychedelic is that it will
speed up schizophrenia and crazy people
and then we'll just have way too much
crazy people in this world if mushrooms,
yeah,
maybe or maybe they're going to be crazy
anyway.
I mean there is an argument for that.
That's there's a certain amount of
people.
That was the what was in the culture
high where they talked about it
accelerating psychosis and paranoia and
all the different issues and they were
saying there's no jump.
Even though more people are smoking pot
than ever.
There's no statistical jump in the
amount of people that are psychotic for
weed but.
But mushrooms I think will definitely
break you.
If you have mild schizophrenia and
you're going to get it later in life,
you'll probably speed it up by twice
your scientists throwing that around.
But I do think that pot,
if you eat it,
is just as likely to do a un maybe even
more so because pot if you eat it,
is not reassuring.
Like there's no sweetness to the,
to the overdose when you're,
when you're eating pot,
it's just fear,
fear and death and spiral and I don't
know what you trip out about when you,
um,
when you take my shrimps heart or not
mushrooms,
edible pot,
but for it's always like mortality and
the death of friends and people getting
sick around you and the body ceasing to
work properly.
Especially people that I know like you
that smoke cigarettes and shit like
that.
I freak out about you when I eat pot.
I do because I feel like there's people
around me that are poisoning themselves.
They don't see it.
I'm like,
oh jesus,
what is he doing?
Fuck they eating pot is.
That's the.
For me,
it was like one of the big paranoia
inducers of all the different
secretarial part anymore.
Don't be a pussy,
get back in their head of the dea.
Tried to highlight this statement so you
can read it.
This was like two weeks ago.
He said this in a report with conference
call.
If you want me to say that marijuana is
not dangerous.
I'm not going to say that because I
think it is.
Do I think it's as dangerous as heroin?
Probably not.
I'm not an expert or who's the fucking
expert.
It's hilarious.
That's the head of the dea and he's not
an expert and saying stupid shit.
That marijuana is dangerous.
I think it is.
You think it's dangerous?
Chuck rosenberg,
you fucking dunce.
That's so goofy.
You know it's not dangerous.
You know what's dangerous?
Idiots.
Dangerous.
If you give them wiffle ball bats,
if you give them spoons and electrical
sockets,
you know,
give him a fork and a toaster.
They're dangerous.
People are dumb,
man.
Heroin is clearly more dangerous than
marijuana.
Okay.
He said that.
Hold on.
Then this week,
rosenberg evolved further after a press
briefing on wednesday where people's
shit in his mouth,
he told reporters that heroin is clearly
more dangerous than marijuana.
According to huffington post.
Rosenberg said he's still considers
marijuana to be harmful and dangerous,
but was willing to make a firm
distinction between it and other
substances.
While he's a fool,
you can't say harmful and dangerous
unless you have data.
You are a dea agent.
You're the head guy.
You should have data,
you know.
That's the whole idea.
Like,
can you say that aspirin is dangerous?
Yes,
you can.
You know why?
Because aspirin,
regular old aspen kills a fuckload of
people every year a lot.
Thousands.
They die from it.
He overdosed from aspirin.
If you take too much as like,
okay,
let's guess what,
guess how many do you think die every
year from aspirin?
Now that you know that people die from
asthma,
right?
I'd probably say 70,000
people.
30,000
people here.
Brilliant.
I was going to say a few hundred.
Well,
now I'm just thinking that a lot of
people have aspirin and that's probably
something that people try to overdose to
kill himself on a.
I know aspirin also saves people's lives
because that's what you're supposed to
take if you're feeling like you're going
to have a heart attack and also they say
as a preventative measure,
taken a little bit of aspirin because
aspirin is an antiinflammatory and taken
anti-inflammatory.
The big issue with health or one of the
big issues I should say is inflammation.
It's a big cars or have a lot of
different diseases and that's why they
say that if you clean up your diet,
your body becomes less inflamed.
You have.
That's one of the benefits of cryogenic
chamber to.
They think that the cryo
cryo treatments provide those cold shock
proteins and anti inflammation responses
and they clean up inflammation inside
the body leading to less disease.
That's one of the theories behind it.
How long do you do that at a time.
Three minutes.
Is it like torture?
Three minutes or it says like,
okay,
all right,
this is fun.
Almost too long.
It's cold as fuck dude.
Fda reverses its position on daily
aspirin.
Use this man they used to tell you,
you need to take aspirin if you haven't
had a heart attack,
step away from the asprin bottle.
If you're one of the 40 million
americans,
take aspirin every day.
Wow.
40 million.
The fda says,
look,
see how many people have you had a
guest?
Jamie,
how many people do you think died?
Seven hundred 50.
Okay.
I said,
what?
40,000
each year.
All right,
here we go.
I'm saying 200 animal causes.
Oh,
15,000,
15,000.
Oh my god.
Look at this.
Each year,
15,000
people die in 100,000
people are hospitalized as a result of
aspirin and other n s a nonsteroidal
antiinflammatories.
Wow.
That's not supposed to give kids and
they have a fever.
Is that tylenol?
Dude,
listen to this.
I don't know,
but listen to this crazy statistic.
Aspirin kills 400 percent more people
than the swine flu.
Nearly 100,000
americans die every year from his
adverse reactions to fda approved
prescription drugs.
What?
That's insane.
Did you know that?
God damn.
Yeah,
these numbers are nuts.
This.
That's incredible,
man.
One hundred and 7,000
patients are hospitalized annually for
nonsteroidal antiinflammatories,
which also includes,
by the way,
ibuprofen.
Ibuprofen is also a nonsteroidal anti
inflammatory.
That's the period one,
right?
No,
no.
Ibuprofen,
advil,
headache stuff.
Oh,
advils the best.
So best for headaches and anything you'd
like muscle aches,
torn muscles or anything.
Why do you,
why do you like advil or ibuprofen?
Tylenol sorta like I think if I had to
guess,
I think dulls the pain more,
whereas ibuprofen gets the source of the
pain more,
which is inflammation,
but uh,
most athletes prefer ibuprofen.
I think it was like less risk factors
too,
but apparently a lot of people get
fucked up by antiinflammatories.
I just can't believe it's that high.
The numbers are nuts,
man.
Swine flu is safer than aspirin.
A 16,500
nonsteroidal anti inflammatory deaths
occur among patients with rheumatoid
arthritis
or osteoarthritis each year in the
United States.
Whoa.
That's a nutty number,
man.
Sixteen thousand 500 deaths
from,
from anti-inflammatory pills from
ibuprofen and aspirin.
Wow.
So those,
those drugs are 1000 percent more deadly
than swine flu.
It was accidental deaths.
Does it say that like does anyone use
note to commit suicide?
And people definitely use to commit
suicide,
but it's hard.
That's all bad suicide apparently.
That's a rough one.
It takes a long time.
Then to my headaches gone.
I feel great.
I feel too.
Okay.
What do you think is the number one
method of suicide?
Right.
Definitely.
Or cutting.
Cutting.
Cutting your nanny.
I know girls cut in their name and
trying to kill themselves,
so I would imagine cutting it after they
fuck you.
They're like,
what am I doing?
Something.
I've known a lot of cutters.
It's weird.
How many cutters are out in los angeles
and I've done many cutters.
It's all the girls you're dating.
It's the pool you're drawing from.
Most guys are like,
what the fuck is he talking about?
People are listening to this right now
going,
dude,
most people don't cut themselves.
Most people don't cut themselves.
Brian,
have you seen that new?
A three d projector display?
It's one of the most change.
The subject dying.
I would just want.
Before we get into that,
I just really wanted to.
What do you think the number one method
for suicide is or to see if you had a
gas cutting,
cutting,
cutting risks.
Really cutting throat.
Jumping off.
Something.
So I'm going to say overdose.
I would say overdose,
but gunshots got to be in there
somewhere.
All right,
let's let's google the number one method
of suicide.
Number one,
death by chocolate.
No,
it's funny.
When you write number one method in
google,
homicide comes up first.
That's what the google suggestion to
fill in the blank.
Number one,
method of homicide.
How many people just google them because
they fucking hate their wife or their
husband like kesha?
Shit.
What's the best motor?
That's your own personal cash,
joe.
No,
it's not.
Yeah,
because I asked.
I have two different things.
When I type in stuff at different things
come up,
but then you have your stuff please in
google if you never googled that before,
I've never googled that before.
Wait,
what?
You put type in number one.
Method of for one method of time.
I say I see fuck off.
Do you know though,
if you're logged in,
you're logged in?
No.
Sometimes it comes up different because
I said something like,
we're wrong,
we're way wrong.
What were really wrong?
Number one,
his firearm,
so shooting 50 percent makes sense.
Fifty percent,
they shoot themselves 24 percent.
They hang themselves or suffocate
poisoning,
which I thought was number one is only
16 percent.
Jumping off shit,
jamie thought two point three percent
cut one percent.
One point,
one point eight percent drowning is one
point.
One percent fire is zero point four
percent.
Woo.
Who would do
that?
That's crazy.
Transporter related.
That means you jump in front of a truck
transporter.
What a weird euphemism transporter
related.
That's zero point four percent.
I'm going to die by transporting.
Yeah.
How weird men firearms 50.
That's America though as America shall
we do.
When in doubt,
take it out so we scary way to die
knowing that you're gonna pull that
trigger and it's all going to go blank,
but I've known more than one person
that's done it in my lifetime.
I've known several people that have
killed themselves with guns.
The are the weird article.
It's like when someone doesn't like that
they go,
you know,
we need to change the gun laws.
Like when someone kills someone with a
gun,
we need to change gun laws.
Well I guess it's kind of easier to kill
someone if you have a gun,
but if somebody wants to kill you,
it's because they want to kill you.
It's not because they have a gun.
It's not like you have a gun and go
talking about fucking killing somebody.
Now that I got this gun.
No you don't.
You only use a gun to kill somebody
because you want to kill them unless
it's an accidental gun shooting and then
you're dealing with a totally different
situation.
But the idea that giving someone a gun
makes them more likely to kill people.
I'm not sure if I buy that.
When the la riots were going on,
a lot of people had their own personal
firearms and uh,
this guy I know he said he had to like
go on the roof of his apartment with a
gun because they were trying to break
into his house and stuff like that.
And he actually had to shoot somebody
shot somebody that in like the arm or
something like that.
I think he said,
who is this guy?
I don't want to say.
It might be a bullshitter.
I can tell you off air is a bullshitter.
No,
absolutely not.
Occasionally.
Never.
Yeah.
No.
What's it dictates like a popcorn.
Your poop.
I think that um,
anthony bordain covered that on one of
his shows.
Um,
the riots in Korea town where the
koreans had to arm themselves,
get on top of their buildings because
all the cops were in beverly hills.
Remember that shit?
Korea town just sorta got ransacked.
And these guys were on top of their
roofs with rifles.
They were getting in trouble for having
guns out.
But um,
if you look,
there was like this giant wall of cars
that guarded beverly hills.
It was really kind of fucked up and
racist and creepy.
There was a creepy moment the way that
police shielded parts of los angeles for
the riots and didn't do anything to
protect other parts.
And obviously they were given mandates.
Obviously there was someone that was
telling them what they're supposed to do
and not supposed to do,
but the weird choice.
It was just so openly and clearly defend
wealthy people.
There's a lot to lose in the wealthy
people's houses and worth millions and
billions of dollars in light of you.
Total stories and.
Yeah,
but,
but so the poor people and their stores
aren't worth as much as I can get
replaced.
Easier than like a painting that was
made by the vinci.
No,
no,
no.
You're not looking at it right there.
They're talking about businesses.
The talk there was these people were on
businesses.
These businesses probably got a million
dollars worth of merchandise and their.
Their business is getting broken into.
It's really not that much different than
a rich person's house.
It's just the fact that it's a business
in Korea town that was in new nwa movie
was cool seeing them remake that riot.
Yeah.
No.
There's an article about art thieves and
about how little do you read that today
was out today about how few works of art
ever get recovered when there's art
theft is really interesting.
There's,
when I lived in boston about 25 years
ago,
there was this big art,
a big stolen art event where these
people broke into the.
I think it was.
I don't remember which I want to say the
getty,
but um,
no,
I'm wrong.
It's not the getty museum.
There was a.
No,
no,
no.
It was a museum in boston and it was a
big time museum and these guys broke
into a 25 years ago and stole a shitload
of rembrandt's.
And like,
here it is.
What is the two suspects?
Is that what you're talking about?
I guess 25 years ago.
These guys are dead now though.
But they are.
When did this come out?
Just recently.
This articles recently,
August 7th.
Ha.
Um,
the two men suspected to masquerading as
police officers to robin art museum of
$500,000,000
with the masterpieces in 1990 or dead.
The fbi say two years ago,
investigators announced they knew who
stole 13 works,
including paintings by rembrandt and
vermeer.
I don't know who that dude is from
boston,
isabella stewart gardner museum.
That's where it is,
but they refused to elaborate saying
only the investigator was investigation
was focused on recovering the artwork so
this the suspects are dead.
What's butts interested in $500,
million dollars worth of art and no
one's ever recovered the art.
So someone's got the art.
Do you think it's just like North Korea?
They just have like a bunch of galleries
like yes,
we have all the most famous american
paintings and you know what I mean?
Like I think it's rich people.
I think it's really,
really rich people that don't give a
fuck where that art came from and they
have a private collection and they walk
by it and they laugh.
You kNow that they bought a rembrandt,
that they have a picasso,
but I think that it's dangerous for them
because if they get caught,
they know what that fucking thing is.
It's like if you,
if you have a ram brand,
your wall,
I don't know about you but me,
I would have no idea what it is.
Someone to have to tell me,
you know,
but as someone who's like a serious art
collector enough that they're willing to
spend millions of dollars on a painting,
they're going to know exactly what that
thing is,
but people are creepy man.
People that are collectors and
collectors of things.
People get real creepy about real
specifics like they want it picasso.
They have a rim brand.
They have a this guy or that guy and
they've needed picasso,
picasso,
but nothing is on the market and then
some guy comes up to you and says,
I know something that's about to go on
the market and right now it is in a
collection that is public and it will no
longer be public and someone will own it
and it could be you.
Would you be interested in this?
And you're like,
well,
when are we talking here?
Like what are we saying?
Well,
we'll show you a photograph and I'll
show you what it is.
And they'll go,
well,
maybe what are we talking here and what?
We talked about $2,000,000.
Oh,
okay.
I think we could work something out and
then they have to figure out how to
exchange money or it doesn't get traced
and then have it looked at a praise to
make sure it's real.
I mean that's,
that's,
that's tough.
That whole black market thing where
people have been busted doing that,
they'd been busted doing that with
statues.
There was a rome roman statue that they
brought.
This guy in.
Bryan county told me the story and then
I went and listened to it on something
else where this guy had this statue and
all day had spent so much money at
praising it and they bought it and they
brought in this expert and the expert
literally looked at it for a few minutes
and goes,
can you get your money back?
And he was like,
what are you talking about?
He goes,
can you get your money back?
This is fake.
You need to get your money back.
It's like why?
And apparently he had bought it from a
legitimate source,
but the legitimate source had been
swindled.
It's like they can figure out a way to
actually add mold shit to make it look
super old.
They burry things underground and add
mold to them.
Like they figure out a way to have.
Because if you can find something like,
um,
something that's like really old like
that.
Somebody gave me a coin mark.
Gordon gave me a coin.
It's an 1800 year old coin from rome,
but it is a fuck load of them.
Like,
you know,
they made a bunch of them.
This guy,
whoever the guy was at the time had a
shitload of his coins made.
You can get ahold of them.
They're not cheap,
but you can get them.
But a statue from back then,
like a,
just a really complex well worked piece
of sculpture is probably worth insane
amounts of money if there's only one of
them.
And it's 1800 years old,
2000 years old,
it's probably worth millions of dollars.
So if someone could sit around and
figure out how to fake it.
so you make one,
you make it real close,
then you slowly chip away at it and add
to it and then figure out a way to
simulate erosion and then figure out a
way to get this,
uh,
this mold in it.
And this mold was apparently the right
mold for the area,
so it had a lot of people fooled.
but this one art expert just looked at
it and say like,
this is,
this is not right.
This is not real.
Like he just knew you could just tell
because he'd just seen so many of them.
Whereas most people,
I mean if you're a guy who's your,
your expertise is in appraising ancient
statues,
you develop a finely honed sense of what
an ancient statue it looks like.
So for him it was like really obvious,
like right away,
like the hue is off.
Something's off,
this can't be real.
Holy shit.
You got to get your money back quick.
Whereas,
you know,
uri,
be like,
whoa,
do you dislike 3000 years old?
I heard it's 5,000
years old.
We'd both be retarded fucking staring at
the stupid thing.
Meanwhile,
mike from calabasas made it fat jermaine
jew and it doesn't make anything,
doesn't mean what does this movie
documentary tim's vermeer that for me or
just came up on here and it made me
think of it someone.
I don't remember which guest brought it
up,
but this is a really,
really great documentary.
Pendula made a millionaire guy.
He actually runs the company that makes
the newtek tricaster we use here.
He figured out this really long process
of how to recreate a.
He made a forgery but no one knew how to
make the forgery and he spent years
figuring out how this guy,
vermeer actually was making these photo
realistic paintings and then figured out
how to do it himself and was making
paintings.
I like a factory almost that we're
indecipherable from actual vermeer
distinguishable.
Yeah.
Oh wow.
Amazing art guys.
It's a really cool documentary.
Really worth checking out.
I heard good things about this.
It's awesome.
I'm like,
I'd really like to watch it again just
to get inspired to the amount of work
this guy put in.
Anytime penn jillette gets involved in
something that's always going to kick
his ass.
He's a smart dude.
He looks weird now though.
He's lost a lot of weight.
I never say that it's bad for someone to
be healthy or unhealthy for so long and
kind of recognize them as being this big
fat guy and now all of a sudden he's
like super thin.
It's actually.
Norton is like really thin right now.
It's really weird.
Se folks healthiest.
He texted me the other day about cryo
chambers wants to start freezing that I
sent you guys that link a three new
three d display that doesn't require
glasses.
We've talked about it in the past.
A lot of uh,
what would be so cool.
It was not three d tvs but not having to
wear glasses and watch a tv and stuff.
And gizmodo actually had a pretty good
article uSing care santa maria as an
example of the three d technology and
it's using a whole bunch of different
projectors and screens.
But I guess it's really realistic,
like if you're staring at and you walk
around her,
it,
it looks like her standing right in
front of you and then they have a low.
So it's a hologram.
It kind of is a hologram.
But I think the goal of fullscreen and
the young Jamey.
Um,
so here's,
that's a fake dude or real dude.
No,
this is a real dude.
This is how they're actually showing
they make it.
Those are all cameras around him.
I believe her lights,
it said 30 cameras.
So those are just lights.
So the 30 cameras are capturing 30
different images.
Right?
And so the three rows of 10 images.
Yeah.
So they're recording all of him and all
the different angles.
A morgan spurlock.
That's the supersize me guy.
And so they're recording him moving and
all sorts of different ways.
And then they,
what do they do with it?
Oh,
see now this is showing what their
feeling
of filming,
like if you were to walk around.
Wow.
And then,
uh,
so they can take this w what we're
looking at and somehow or another
project it in front of you,
like a hologram,
right?
Yeah.
If you like that magic leap technology
server thing kind of a.
Hold on.
Let's see.
Let's turn this up a little so we can
hear what's going on.
6,000
led lights and 50 high definition
cameras.
After they captured all this data,
they put it together to make a three d
model of me.
And then they were able to project that
onto this screen as you see me now.
Wow.
So it looks like it is a screen,
but it's a three d screens.
If you were to stare at it,
you would be able to walk to the side,
to the left,
to the right,
the hit this guy who was a holocaust
survivor.
Imagine going through the holocaust all
the way to 2015 and they turned you into
a crazy three d animated thing.
What series of generational jumps that
guys pass through?
Just think how cool it's going to be
when this gets a little bit better in
the future.
Like the hall of presidents at
disneyland,
you know,
and stuff like that where you're
actually,
holy shit,
abraham lincoln sitting right in front
of me.
Yeah,
you're going to get real holographs real
holograms rather that are just,
you probably be shocked when your hand
goes through them and they're going to
get to a point,
especially if this magic leap is in any
way indicative of what it's going to
really look like when it's done because
right now you're looking at it and it's
like,
how much of that is proof of concept?
How much of that is the actual video of
magic leap?
If you don't know what magic leap is?
Google.
It's a wild new hologram thing that
they're doing where they have like a,
an elephant dancing inside a person's
palm.
TheY had a um,
a little ballerina that was on a girl's
bed.
It was like a four inch ballerina,
but I don't know.
do you know like how much of that is?
That was a demo.
Like I think that's not real.
I think that just saying what in the
future will look like.
I remember reading someone has tried it,
but he had to be very careful about what
he was allowed to say.
You actually experienced it.
You had a very,
very rudimentary,
very early version of as a giant
football house,
how helmet,
size thing you had to wear.
It was projecting things in front of his
eyes on it to us screen like thing,
but they're doing some called light
field augmentation.
It's there make.
It's like brand new technology that no
one else has used,
so we can't compare it to you.
I wonder what,
how they're projecting it.
Like if.
So right now he's got to wear this
helmet thing and then eventually they'll
break it down to like a google glass
type size or sunglasses or something
like that,
but I wonder how they're projecting it
in front of you.
Like how is it just a.
Is it a recreation of three d?
Yeah.
They're
putting.
They're actually projecting light into
your eye.
Like we're,
we're,
we're expecting,
excuse me,
accepting light into our eyes right now.
Like throw irises,
but they're going to shoot light your
eye,
like lasers
stuff.
How long before someone goes blind or as
I cancer,
they're saying now that cell phones
absolutely cause cancer was serious.
Yeah.
There's a study that says that they're
pretty positive that cellphones cause
cancer.
It's going to good to.
Or most people's is there a such thing
as hand cancer because that's what would
be the most right from texting all day.
I don't think people get hand cancer
that much.
Hands are pretty durable.
Um,
but uh,
let's see.
This cell phones cause cancer cell
phones in the cancer risk.
Yeah.
There was a recent article about it
where they were talking about.
I'm trying to find the recent version of
it.
Don't smoke yourself.
Own berkeley.
Berkeley says cell phones cause tumors.
This is from a just a couple months ago.
Yeah.
Berkeley is the first city to,
of the park is filled with hippies
firstly to mandate cell phone carriers,
informed buyers of potential radiation
exposure.
A neuroscientist on why it's premature
to claim co phones costing answer.
That might've been when I left read from
the daily beast.
Hmm.
I mean it makes sense though.
I think that is probably.
It's probably not good to have all these
wifi signals running through our fucking
houses constantly.
I mean,
how could it be good that you're
throwing hundreds of megabytes around
the room in the air?
Right?
I mean,
this phone is.
I mean this,
this laptop's downloading shit right
now.
It's completely unconnected by wires.
Yours is as well.
We there is.
There's movies in the air right now
around us.
There's like dick pics right next to
your team
radios,
radio signals in the air,
cell phones,
signals or signals or in the air?
Yeah.
Well they say that fucks with bees.
That bs apparently they hear it like a
jackhammer,
like the ways the way bees communicate.
They're.
I think they're pretty positive that
bees are negatively impacted by the
sounds and the signals that are flying
around them all the time.
Why fi cell phone radio,
all that jazz.
That it's fucking with their peace.
See,
I don't know how much we feel or how
much it impacts us,
but what I do know is every time I go
somewhere where there's no cell phone
was like Alaska or Montana or something
like that where you're out in the real
wilderness.
It seems different.
Like the actual physical environment of
the air seems different.
Like when you're standing out there
you're like,
what is this is a different kind of.
Solitude is a different kind of silence.
It's just like real silence.
It's not like there's.
There's something missing in the air and
it could be just totally bullshit.
It could be a placebo.
It could be just the fact that you know
that you can't get a cell phone signal
and there's no one for miles.
You can't see anybody that it just like
gives you this feeling of solitude that
sort of accentuates the,
you know,
the quiet of the environment,
but it might not be.
It might be.
There might be an actual physical thing
that you're feeling in your brain that
you can't quite put your finger on,
but it's there all the time.
It just makes me wonder though,
if we could look at it like something
like a nap though and be like,
well,
day would feel it first.
You know,
they're so small that just a tiny gnat
or what are those little red dots that
are insects that are always like walking
around on bricks and stuff.
Even though I'm taLking about like a
bright orange dot and you're like,
I'll just accept that.
That's a bug.
That orange dot.
No,
no,
no.
we in talk to him about this little
dots.
No,
they're like these little insects that
looks like a little red dot and it's
like a pixel,
but they're super small.
I don't know if they haven't been
California.
Maybe
there's two articles in a row here.
It's official.
Cellphones are killing bees and then
right below it,
cell phones don't kill bees.
One of them is from 2011,
May 21st.
The other one is may 20,
May 19th,
2011.
So hilarious.
How's the fuck?
His sermon is supposed to figure it out
to be squirt.
I think they were saying that interferes
with them.
So let's see.
Bees and still a cell phones interfere.
Let's do this turn.
Fear study links.
Bees declined to cell phones.
This was on cnn.
Yeah,
and they're saying the cell phone
signals somehow or another cell phone
radiation may be contributing to the
decline in bee populations in some areas
of the world.
You know,
radiolab.
I had this interesting story about bees
were in China.
They because of what?
What are you.
What are you pulling up here?
Jamie says it doesn't say the government
though.
Those are criminals.
this is a criminal website.
This is.
Might be.
Might as well be isis.
Who knows?
They're telling you the truth.
I'm a.
But this is the huffington post,
bro says it's real.
What was I just saying?
Oh,
decline and bs in China.
They did this study where they found out
that they had rapidly declining bee
populations for whatever reasons,
pollution,
whatever.
And so they decided that they were going
to have to figure out another way to
pollinate some of their plants.
So these apple trees,
so they hand pollinated the apple trees
and their yield went through the roof
because apparently when you have bees do
it,
bees are sloppy fucks.
They don't even know what they're doing.
It's like you're asking someone to do
something and they don't even know what
they're doing and they're idiots.
You know,
bees are just little robots,
little insect robots,
they just run around and they,
they,
they get this pollen and they
accidentally spread it.
They're not doing it on purpose.
but when you have people do it on
purpose,
they had people doing it with paint
brushes and when they had the people
doing it with paint brushes,
like significant increase in yield.
But then people wanted more money and
then they realized that,
you know,
in China,
like the more lucrative the business
became,
the more people organized and said we
want more money.
The more they decided it was cost
prohibitive.
But they tried.
This is all from a radio lab,
podcasts call,
I think it was called worth.
Don't quote me on that though,
but it was all about how much are things
worth.
And one of the things that they were
talking about were how much,
how much is it worth to have bees
pollinate these plants that you don't
think about it that way.
You think about it like,
oh,
it's just a part of nature,
but if you had to put a monetary value
on it,
then maybe you would think more
carefully about maintaining healthy bee
populations.
And I think the number they were using
was in the billions that having healthy
bee populations that pollinate plants is
worth x amount of billions of dollars in
labor.
Whether or not that's true.
Yeah.
It seems like you could eat like those
little robot drone things.
We could almost make her own robot bees
in the future.
Well,
they have done that.
Yeah,
Monsanto did that.
Monsanto has drone bees.
You're seeing them now.
pull them up.
Jamie.
Monsanto drone bees.
Where you see this.
This is the idea I think is once we
pollute the atmosphere to the point
where bees can't live anymore,
they're going to release these fucking
insect hordes traveling to the field.
He's horrible little monster
spice and dynamics just released a new
robot video running through a forest and
it's very creepy looking.
It looks like an army soldier.
Those fucking things are terrifying man.
Boston dynamics or they make some of the
scariest shit.
Did you find any monsanto bs drone be I
sent you the link of the other robot
when they're going to look at that while
you're looking at.
I'm trying to.
The only stuff.
I'm fine on this monsanto or sites that
don't look legit.
Yeah.
Robotic bees to pollinate monsanto
crops.
It sounds like a troll.
First news that wordpress dot jude.
That's it though.
Go to it and they'll show you the.
The b.
No,
but that's where I'm at.
Is it fake?
Go to snopes is word press.
It's from harvard.
Says the harvard monolithic be harvard.
Yeah.
Microbiotics lab had been working with
its micro air vehicles projects since
2009 working on.
It's borrowing from the biomechanics and
social organization of bees.
That team of researches is undergoing
the creation of a tiny wing robot.
Look at this fucking thing,
man.
Is that real?
Seems real so size of a penny.
whoa.
So they cut that.
Be out of that thing.
The little circuit board publish
reports.
no lab also described potential military
uses,
surveillance and mapping,
but the dime size,
cyber bees have yet to be outfitted with
neuro
hacks and tips.
Stingers.
Yuck.
This looks real as fuck.
Dude.
This is fake.
This is a really elaborate sort of a
hoax that are.
It's like final at some college,
you know,
some engineers.
I say that was my final.
Yeah,
it could be,
but I don't think it's anything of the
realm of possibility.
Oh,
look at this.
It is real.
Oh my god.
Look at this fucking thing.
This is the little tiny fake bug.
So how's this thing fly?
See you.
Oh wow.
Those things go so fast you can't even
see it.
So they move just like a real bug,
like the same sort of thing.
Printed circuit madness,
a versatile process for creating
machines at the millimeter scale.
They can't create complex electrical and
mechanical systems using a variety of
techniques.
I don't see it flying
process well suited to mass production.
It seems like some parallel
manufacturing,
large numbers of robotic device
sounds like an idea again.
Yeah.
they didn't fly.
They just showed the wings buzzing when
she could've just hooked up to a
battery.
Fine bitch.
Why would you show us something that
flies but not have it fly?
That seems silly,
right?
Yeah.
It doesn't seem right,
but that boston dynamics robot is real
and it looks like a soldier.
It looks like star wars running through
a look at that thing.
It's so awful.
There's a video also have it.
This is just an animated gif,
but it's terrifying.
It's a.
It's weird because it's hooked up right
now to a giant tube in the back of it,
but that's just for now is aren't they
owned by google now or something like
that?
Prostitute dynamics.
Skynet.
You mean that they're showing all their
different robots right now in this
video.
My friend who worked for google doesn't
work for google anymore,
so now I can't find out when they're
going to attack.
I don't know.
I was hoping that she could at least
send me the batsignal skynet's going to
go live and these robots are going to
start attacking,
but does she,
does she works somewhere better like
apple or something like that?
She moved to another corporation that
I'll tell you about later.
But look at this,
um,
this thing,
walking on those uneven rocks.
Oh shit.
Look,
it gets hit.
It lifts his leg up and check the leg
kick balance.
That's a 20 pound ball that slammed into
it at 20 pound piece of metal or 20
kilograms.
We don't know.
Imagining these things during riots.
They're just going to throw these robots
out there.
They're not going to have any real
judgment skills.
Just grab,
you know,
keep out the real worries that this is
how we're going to do our wars,
that these things are going to go into
cities and just kill people.
And this is a robot versus robot until
robots get to people and they decimate
human populations.
And then we,
uh,
that's the wars we have.
We send robots to kill people and then
we sell,
send robots to kill robots that are
trying to kill people and then we send
our robots to kill the people that
created a robot to kill the people.
Know we got robot wars.
Yeah,
that's possible,
man.
One hundred percent.
It's gonna start off.
Pretty cool though.
Like,
oh my god,
we're getting attacked,
but it's a robot attack and we have
robots and we're just watching robots on
tv here.
Yeah,
for a little bit.
So jamie,
there is a video of it.
Just look up robotic bees could change
the world and then go to a.
It's pretty far down like maybe seven
eighth into the video.
You'll see this thing is attached with a
very small wire,
but it actually is flying.
It's fucking crazy to look at man.
That's really weird.
It's a three minute videos.
Go to bella to 40 something and you can
see the actual,
a fake bug flying,
but it's connected just like that robot
is,
you know,
the road was connected with a hose in
the back with wires.
This is connected with a very small
wire,
but it's real.
So it's not just a proof concept.
They just have to figure out a power
source that makes sense,
but they're not as the robot bees are
fucking crazy and creepy.
But what's really creepy is see that
thing will get that thing flying when
it's real.
I mean it's mimicking a hummingbird or a
b.
But look at it.
We'll see.
This is an actual baby,
but look at it right there.
I mean,
that is flying.
That's nuts man.
Um,
here's what's scarier though.
Go to 10.
Incredible micro robots.
This is fucking nuts,
man.
What way do you see this video?
Ten.
Incredible micro robots.
Micro and then dash robots.
Top one.
Yeah,
that's it.
Check this shit out.
This is one style that flies around like
little helicopters.
Look at these fucking things,
man.
They come out of these boxes.
So imagine that you're sitting in your
office.
This is fake,
right?
This is proof of context.
So yeah,
but look at some of these ones that
they're creating.
These are all the different.
Um,
so this is self organizing systems,
research lab from harvard,
these things organized and they can
figure out where to go look,
look at this elapsed time,
11 hours elapsed time,
five hours,
and they form shapes.
They go into certain positions like
this,
one of them climb up a wall.
So some of these are prototypes,
some of these proof of concepts.
Some of these are just theories,
but these eggheads work on this stuff.
Right?
So awesome.
Did you see the video of the,
uh,
where they downloaded the brain of a
worm and put it into a,
like a little lego robot thing and it's
just like running around hitting walls
and going up.
So I thought this,
I've watched it,
I watched it twice in the first time.
I thought it was a woman's brain and I
was like,
oh my god,
did you see that?
They download a woman's brain into a
machine to my friend.
I'm like,
no,
they did.
I'm like,
yeah.
And I like put them like this worm.
But the whole time I thought this woman
is,
she's just getting here.
Well she's a worm.
She can't think she's a lego or
whatever,
but that's funny when you think they
would do,
if you put your brand a lego,
definitely probably go in circles and
hit a wall.
It would just run over to a laptop and
just research fat jew all day just
hanging out on mfc.
There's a bunch more in that,
uh,
that video to one of them is a typer.
One of them is typing with the top 10
organizing ones.
One of them is this little thing that
goes over a piece of paper and a,
like a typewriter would do,
but types it.
So like you put a message in this little
thing and then you put this little thing
on a piece of paper and it will print
out like a typewriter would what your
message is,
which is really weird.
Yeah.
You could see that one at like,
um,
let's see here.
Yeah,
check it out jamie.
Oh wow.
For labs.
How hilarious.
I don't think it's the same info,
but it's like a 2:25
go to 2:25.
Look at this fucking thing brian.
I mean,
I think that typing's kind of the idea
of a typewriter is kind of outdated.
There it is.
Cool.
Look at that.
It just floats across a piece of paper
and writes what you wanted to say was
fucking very strange.
Right?
Zuta labs,
ufa.
Look at that.
It's really neat,
but it seems like that's old technology
that's just not even created yet.
He ain't know that seems like I had
already been made.
Like they like it seems.
What would be more like having paper
that you could just take a flash and
print it by just doing like a xerox
machine on nights where you're just
flashing some paper,
like a negative photo or something,
but that's 100 percent going to happen.
Yeah.
I think also what we were looking at
earlier,
the cara santa marina thing,
the three d,
they're gonna be able to do that with
just going to take a video,
something when your cell phone and be
able to send it to jamie and jamie will
watch like princess leia help will be
one.
You're my only hope.
Yeah,
that's going to happen.
It's just,
it's just a matter of us staying alive
long enough to see things that we'd
never thought could be real.
It's not that far away.
This is people that we don't even know.
You don't even know they're working on
these things.
Nobody knows of them,
but yet they are like that close to
going public on their fucking.
Everybody has to swipe key cards before
they go into the building.
They check your bag.
They make sure you don't bring your
phone.
Your phone has to go into a bucket when
you go into the,
into the laboratory,
because this is all propriety.
Proprietary shit.
They're checking their.
They probably have those fucking fake
buttons that are cameras and shit.
I guess your glasses,
fucking glasses.
Glasses.
Now they have glasses with little tiny
cameras and I'm literally like so hard
to see.
If you look at yourself,
he camera look a little that goddamn
lenses like the selfie one,
like the one on the back is tiny,
right?
Look at my iphone here,
but the one the front is fucking stupid.
Tiny.
It's so little and it's good.
It's really good.
I mean,
look how good a selfie camera is.
I mean they,
they do a fucking incredible job of
capturing your,
like,
look at this,
look at that.
Yeah.
That's a tiny ass little little pinpoint
camera and it's got everyone in this
room to the point where you could
broadcast periscope from this thing
that's like a sharpie if you took a
sharpie and dotted a page with it.
Just that's how big that camera is.
And yet it's crystal clear.
So that could be in your button.
That could be in any.
They're not physically patting you down.
You could easily have something like
that going on.
Yeah.
The one I used in massage parlors,
it looks like a car.
A car alarm.
See you're on the air kitchen.
Oh the fuck man.
But it's a video.
I filmed a 10 80 film massage parlors.
Do you?
No.
Good.
I mean,
the one right now,
it's uh,
it's like,
uh,
actually just looks like a little key
chain,
but if it does,
it does 10,
80 p,
like you had little memory card,
just put it in your computer and next
thing you know,
it's just like,
oh,
you got full video.
You just put it on the nightstand next
to it,
pointed towards the girl hats.
Anything that's really illegal though.
I'm kidding.
I don't do it.
That's the only way.
But you think about what you could do
that with me.
Belts would be an easy one,
right?
Because you could actually hide the
battery and everything in the belt.
You could literally hide the whole thing
and a belt,
they would have to give you your own
outfit.
They would have to make you come into
the lab.
You have to take off all your clothes,
put them in a locker,
and then were some scrub suit that they
provide.
You remember that movie?
A new jack city where they're making
cocaine naked titties.
That's how they had to do it because
they didn't trust anybody and people
would leave with the product.
That's the same thing with these,
these laboratories that are about to go
live with all this crazy technology.
They have to take every precaution
possible to make sure that people don't
go public with their stuff because for
every one of the things about big
inventions,
whether it's the light bulb or the
telephone,
when these things are being worked on,
there's usually a bunch of other people
working on the exact same thing like
scientific minds.
Here's the thing about like innovative
minds are brilliant people.
They don't work in a vacuum for every
nicola tesla who comes up with shit
completely independent of other people's
thoughts.
There's most people what their ideas are
based on.
It's based on the ideas of a bunch of
other people that are sort of like
extrapolated to a point that maybe a few
people saw coming.
You know,
whether it's,
uh,
the idea of a telephone or the idea of
holograms or three d printers are all
these different things.
It's like people kind of see it common
and they're all working on it.
And then this one,
thomas edison motherfucker comes out
with that light bulb and everybody's
like,
wow,
he's a genius.
Thomas edison invented the light bulb
and America was changed.
Where would we be for not the work of
this great man?
Well there's probably about five other
dudes who were working on exactly the
same time.
That's sort of what always happens with
this stuff.
So a lot of it becomes a rush to getting
the funding and getting the patents and
then figuring out how to get it
produced.
But there's usually
probably a bunch of people working on
similar shit.
So like right now when you see this
stuff like these little micro robots,
when you see those big crazy boston
dynamic robots and you see artificial
intelligence and this is all stuff that
they're going public with their probably
so close and so many different labs
developing something that's really gonna
make you shit your pants.
Right?
I got one I thought today.
Would you say some researchers have got
a pig heart to work inside of a primate
for 945 days and it's something they
didn't think was actually possible
before.
They've got a kidney working for 136
days and it says that they're probably
geo engineering some of these pigs to be
better to suit human organ transplants.
Whoa.
Well,
here's something that,
uh,
Dr.
Gordon,
Mark Gordon told me about the,
um,
I was telling him about the success that
I had with getting stem cell shot in my
shoulder.
It's kind of creeping me out,
like my shoulders still makes kinda some
clicks.
It does some weird clicking stuff and
um,
you know,
I kinda,
I kinda feel it,
but I can't say there's any pain.
And um,
I'm practicing archery everyday,
so I'm shooting arrows with.
It's on pulling back.
This new bowl I have is only 70 pounds,
but I'm pulling back 70 pounds 100 times
a day every day and it's not hurting
like the next day it feels like a
little,
like something's going on with it,
but it doesn't hurt.
Whereas it would definitely be hurting
before,
before the stem cells and like lifting
weights doesn't bother it.
Like chin ups,
don't bother it rose,
don't bother it.
All these pushups don't bother it.
All these different things that bothered
it used to bother and it's only been
four weeks,
which freaking me out is how quick it
is.
I talked to daniel cormier,
he's ufc light,
heavyweight champ.
Same shit with the asterisks next to
champ,
but I'm the same shit.
He had an mcl tear,
got some stem cell shot in there.
Bam.
No more swelling.
Feels great and they don't even know how
it works.
They have ideas of how it works,
but they're not really sure how it's
working.
These are nonspecific cells and these
cells go to the injured area and they
somehow or another know what's injured
through the immune system or something.
The utilization of these stem cells
causes injuries to heal way quicker than
it ever did before.
And Dr.
Gordon was telling me about this guy
have gotten a car accident,
gets his chest crushed,
okay,
on the steering wheel,
down to 30 percent heart capacity and
he's fucked.
Can't have sex anymore,
can barely walk.
I mean he just severely,
severely diminished.
Get some stem cells,
shot into his heart,
bam.
Back to 100 percent,
just a few months.
Like what?
A few months,
a few months and it's fucking hard to
work 100 percent now and this is like
apparently this is going on all over the
world.
Like they're just going,
wait,
what?
What,
Like they're just starting to
experiment,
but that's really happening.
It's experiments
because they don't exactly know why this
shit works.
They have some theories and they're
trying it out,
but a lot of people are real cautious
about it,
but they're having some pretty
incredible results with stem cells to
the point where it makes you wonder like
what are they going to have in five
years from now?
Because they didn't even have this 10
years ago,
10 years ago.
Someone,
if you told someone you got stem cells
shot and injury,
they'd be like,
what are you from the future?
But I wonder if there's also because
you're adding something new to the body
that's kind of foreign.
If that passes on through dna or you
know,
like in the future with a clever
question like you have like a baby that
has an external face or something to it
or only works like that,
it's just,
it's their cells that are natural to
your body.
They can do It that way or they can do
it with placenta.
That's how I did it.
Mine.
Mine was from human placenta,
from chicks of vets and sarah and
sections.
They take their placenta in.
Did you get to choose the girl?
No,
I did not.
I don't think they would let you creep,
but they also can take it out of your
fat.
You can have some of my.
No,
I don't want your fat.
My fat.
The idea is you use your own.
Would you get lipo?
Yeah.
What if a guy was like a light post
origin and contacted the show and said,
uh,
I would like to get brian red bands and
free light bulbs.
You know,
I would Totally do it because,
uh,
I,
am lazy.
Now I've noticed that get the more,
the round a muffin top thing has nothing
to do with you drinking every night.
Now I'm excited.
Diet coke,
diet coke called sodium,
uh,
bothered me.
Yeah,
I mean there's something going.
I know I only eat once a day,
so it's so weird that I even have any
issue at all,
but I want,
I really wonder if I just quit drinking
100 percent.
Yeah.
Well it's weird because I only drink
diet sodas and so it's like a Jack
Daniels,
whatever calories isn't Jack Daniels I'm
having,
but if you want to eat one a day,
you have calories to burn.
It's not like I'm eating hot dogs.
You have a sedentary lifestyle.
You like sitting and not doing anything?
Laying.
Yeah,
ross.
Too hard.
You get to say,
yeah,
I'd stay sit on friday that we can just
lay sideways.
You went when you broke up with one of
your girlfriends back in the day,
the one where you went on this rampage
and lost all the weight like you,
you were like fucking determined to look
good.
You decided this is it.
I'm tired of being fat and waddling
around everywhere I was 10 years ago
too.
Yeah.
Awesome.
Well.
Oh,
so you feel like it's harder now because
you're 41,
31 that changed like maybe five years
ago where I'm just like,
holy shit.
Like the energy was already low to begin
with.
Now I wake up tired.
so that's where I have a sleep nap,
sleep apnea because I really do wake up,
just go like,
okay,
I just need to stay awake enough to go
to starbucks and then starbucks
doesn't seem like it works.
The problem with finding out if you have
sleep apnea and you got to go through
one of those sleep studies and those are
annoying.
Right?
I just saW that picture of me.
We have all those electrodes stuck to my
head.
I had it on my blog somewhere.
It's probably still up there,
but it was a.
I had these electrodes stuck all over my
head and like,
like around my eyes and shit.
And then you,
uh,
you try to sleep and this fucking weird
bed and some weird room.
I had the hardest time sleeping,
but once I did I was choking like
clearly they can tell like when your,
when you.
There it is,
there's me covered up with a c.
I did the home version of that.
I just put a drop cam next to my bed and
I had it tell me anytime it hears noises
a or movement and then it would record
it in the clouds.
Then I can just go back and be like,
oh,
there's a noise here.
That's me snoring or that's me moving.
And I noticed that I,
I mean I've been doing it for like a
couple months that,
uh,
that it's mostly I'll snore on nights
that I heavily drink or something like
that.
But it's always at,
at the beginning of my sleep and then I
just,
it's only for like a half hour or so.
So it's not the whole night going like
that or anything like that.
But well heavily when you're drunk and
really exhausted when I'm really
exhausted,
I snore horrible.
Like the worst,
like a one of these hunting trips that I
went on,
me and steven rinella had a hall.
This pig down the sun.
Well I shot this pig and it rolled down
the side of a hill and it was really far
down the hill and the hill was
ridiculously steep like this.
I mean like you couldn't walk up.
It had to crawl up the hill.
You could,
you could crawl up it,
but you literally couldn't stand up
straight.
I mean it was just that steep and it was
a big pig.
It was like 200 plus pound pigs.
So the pig goes rolling down the side of
this hill and we had to figure out how
to get it up the hill so we attach it to
these cables and we had this truck pull
it,
but the cables were rubbing on the rocks
on the hill and they kept snapping.
The cable snapped twice and the pig came
rolling back down and then we had to
stop the pig from rolling down.
So then the guide from the home ranch
said,
all right,
this is what we're gonna do.
We're gonna roll the pig downhill,
going to roll the pig downhill and uh,
I think if you just roll it downhill
you'll get down to the road at the
bottom and I'll just drIve around and
pick you up the road.
So we figured okay,
probably won't be that far and he
totally misjudged.
So um,
not only that,
I shot this pig with like five minutes
left of light.
So it was like if it gets dark at 6:00,
I shot the picket 5:55.
So all this stuff we're doing at in dark
and this is a place that to hone ranch
that has a,
they have a trail camera that picks up
movement,
takes photographs.
So they have this waterhole,
they got pictures of 16 different
mountain lions in this one waterhole and
it's just me and rinella with one gun.
He doesn't even,
I don't think he even had a gun with
them.
I think it
was just me and him.
One gun,
16 mountain lions and a dead pig.
And we're rolling it down this hill.
But you can only go so far because we
got to this point where it's just like
so heavily wooded.
We had to cut up the pig and then we had
to carry it out.
So we have to,
we had to gut this pig would take out
the heart because you eat the heart.
And um,
we got rid of the rest of the organs and
he put one half on his shoulder.
I put one half on my shoulder and then
we had to carry this thing the rest of
the way.
So we're carrying it for miles through
the woods.
And the woods alert gets super steep
hills.
He gets to the bottom.
You're trying to climb over logs mean
it's fucked and it takes hours.
So from 6:00
PM to midnight,
this is what we did.
We just carried this.
You each had 100 pounds on her back,
climbing over woods and trying to figure
out how to get to the fucking where this
truck is.
We finally get to where this truck as we
got back to the cabin and just conked
out.
And apparently I snored so bad that
everybody else in the building didn't
sleep.
I went out there,
got shot with a tranquilizer dart.
Even I even had a mouthpiece and I had a
shitty one at the time.
So you have a better one now you have.
Have you ever tried this new strips,
those work or that's not,
that's not gonna help that I had already
had my nose fixed by then.
It wasn't that.
It's just my.
When you,
uh,
it's a big issue with a weight lifters.
Your neck gets big,
your hole gets smaller,
like the air hole actually gets smaller
and have a big ton.
And so my tongue,
I don't mean to brag,
so you've got a tight thrill and a nice
fat tongue.
And my fat tongue would fall if I'm
lying on my back,
especially falls over the whole,
the air hole and it just chokes.
And so apparently that's what it sounds
like.
I never listened to my snore,
but I've heard you start before.
It's bad.
Yeah.
I remember you snored only.
We went to Japan,
my mouthpiece,
and when I went to sleep,
I don't remember.
I just remember on the plane.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
That'll happen.
Yeah.
They killed a mountain lion on the five
freeway the other day.
good.
Kill them all from the santa monica
mountains.
Cons.
People are too happy about those things
being around.
They're cute though.
There's cool looking.
They just shouldn't be around.
People believe you shouldn't be around
with your.
Shut up.
I hate that fucking line of thinking
that,
that isn't annoying line of thinking.
They're dangerous.
Mountain lions will fuck you up if you
never seen a picture of someone who got
bit by a mountain lion.
There was some poor lady who was on one
of the new shows and uh,
it was so graphic.
She'd been attacked by a mountain lion
on a bike,
pulled her off of her bike.
Someone else tried to beat the thing off
of her and it just had a hold of her
head and just tore face apart.
I mean,
it was just,
it was awful.
There was a video on huff post of a,
a woman's beautiful lullaby to her sick
pig and I don't know if you saw it or
not,
but it's one of those videos that
I'm just cutest,
like human looking eyes,
uh,
I've ever seen in my life.
do you.
Well,
that's the thing about pigs.
I mean this is coming from someone who
just shot one
or just told you about a time I shot
one.
Yeah.
Pigs are really smart man.
They're smart and they kill him.
Like vermin in Texas,
in Texas.
They shoot them out of airplanes there.
They're constantly fucking shoot no
matter airplanes.
There's.
Yeah.
Oh,
this.
I mean if you play this poor pig is
blind and she rescued this pig and so it
has to stay in this hospital.
And I guess jamie have two things at the
same time.
It has to stay in this hospital.
And I guess that one of the things is,
is that uh,
there's so many loud noises at the
hospital that it gets scared and she
comes there when she can and sings to
it.
And it's just one of those videos you
just sit there going,
I don't want to eat bacon or nevermind.
And iT's still,
you begin.
But it was hard to.
Bacon's good is good,
but it was good.
But it is.
It's just weird,
man.
It looks like an old noise in the
background.
Her.
yeah,
this is at a hospital.
Oh,
okay.
I mean that looks like a human
stopped up.
It's almost like a joke.
Let's see if you listen to the song
sound of tractor trailers falling off
cliffs in the background.
It's an old irish lullaby.
She's singing,
but it's a,
it's a nine month old.
A 14 pound piglet.
Yes.
To a million views.
if that was an african baby.
50 views,
right?
Man,
people were brutal.
There was a picture of this fucking
vulture that someone posted.
It was a meme,
I don't think it wasn't funny.
So fat jewish didn't use it,
but it was a meme of a vulture hovering
over a black baby in africa waiting for
this kid to die.
And,
uh,
it was about how many people cared about
this lion,
but how few people care about the amount
of people that starve to death every
year in africa.
Yeah.
Justin wren is going to be on the
podcast again soon.
He's fighting for bella tour now.
And uh,
he's back on the podcast I think in a
week or so.
I gotta I gotta go check the calendar,
but he's back soon to talk about his,
uh,
yeah,
that's the 20 Fourth a week from today
to talk about black widow babies
fighting for bella tour.
And one of the reasons why he's doing
this,
to try to raise awareness for the
pygmies.
He's such an amazing dude.
He's like,
he's a real deal.
Like I always look for likE,
people like that.
I always think like maybe somewhere
along the line he'll reveal and it turns
out that he was really just doing this
for his own profit than these.
But he's not,
I don't think that about him.
But you think that about someone usually
when they have some big car.
Remember kony 2012,
one of my favorite times wagon,
a wagon.
And the guy was a will explain why you
say why can it because the guy was in,
he was putting together this ridiculous
thing to go after joseph kony and you
know,
letting everybody know what a horrible
person kony was.
And then something happened to homeboy,
ilana ballou's in his mind and was in
his underwear running around and traffic
and san diego beaten off in front of
people.
And that was the annacone like you,
you can't,
you have to be a perfect person.
You can't have a great cause.
And also be a nut because then people
just immediately dismiss your cars.
we never heard a peep out of joseph kony
ever since it was 2012 areas.
he's totally naked.
Crank this up so we could hear this guy.
He's running around naked and he's
clapping.
WhaT do you think it was on that?
Oh,
he's,
first of all,
he's gay or then the day is long.
There's no way you could even pretend to
be that gay.
Like faking it.
Yeah.
I don't know.
That seems like alcohol and molly maybe.
I think that's like some serious drugs.
I think that's like a meth move.
yeah.
Yeah.
That's like a mifi sort of behavior and
running around slapping concrete and
angry at everybody.
That's all methy.
Yeah,
matthew,
it's,
it seems method.
It's more popular than I ever thought it
would.
Was it seen as I learned more about
people doing meth and heroin in this
city than I've ever.
Five was actually real life.
Math is super popular.
Math is real popular and an adderalls
real popular too.
And do you talk to doctors and they say
there's not that much difference?
Depends on how much you're taking,
but math in we associate meth with
addiction and we associate math with
addiction.
That shitty behavior,
like you're going to take math,
you're definitely going to go out and
get whacked out and do a bunch of stupid
shit.
That's not necessarily the case.
Some people do maTh and they're fine.
I think it cranked up and then the next
day they feel like shit,
but they don't do it every day.
Whereas we only think of math by the
people that quote unquote abused math.
Imagine if meth became something like
alcohol where you could just go buy it.
Like if you run into someone,
like if you're at a park and you run
into some dude,
he's hammered like,
oh great,
a fucking drunk as annoying.
Why is that any different than running
someone who's left out?
Like there's people that can drink like
you jamie,
you can drink and you're fine.
I've seen you a little silly but you
don't get crazy.
But we all know someone any.
I mean,
every group of people knows at least one
person that can't.
They turned this
office,
whoEver it is,
they go off the rails,
they get crazy and if you ran into that
person in a park and they'll man,
fuck these bitches,
you know,
running around drunk,
he'd be like,
oh great.
A drunk.
Maybe that's the same thing with math.
Maybe you do math and you'd be like all
fucking speedy and you clean your house
up,
but you'd be the same guy.
The next day you'd be like,
ah,
I did some good math last night.
I got a little fucked up.
You know what I mean?
Like we associate,
like if you do math,
you're off the rails out of your fucking
mind.
Done like jesus,
brian's doing meth.
oh no.
But what if alcohol was illegal?
But meth was legal and you know,
you know what brian didn't last line.
He got drunk,
no fucking way.
He was drinking alcohol.
What an idiot.
And you're out there drinking booze,
getting fucked up,
which is totally norMal to us,
but it's only normal because it's a
society sanctioned drug would have math
is just as good or bad for you or just
as just as problematic as alcoholism.
It's just not sanctioned.
So we don't think about that way.
We only associated with those people
fucking claw their face off and lose
their teeth and shit.
Is that what people were referring to?
A speed and like the eighties.
Is that something else?
Yeah,
that's all.
It means.
Different types and schedule,
different classifications of
amphetamines.
But like that was a big thing in
professional pool was guys would uh,
play on amphetamines.
They'd play for 24,
48 hours.
They would play until the other guy
dropped and they would,
uh,
they would gamble the entire time.
And apparently when you're on
aMphetamines you can see things better.
Like you see like the path of the balls
better.
You see like where the ball's going to
go.
Like someone described it to me that
they used to do meth and he said,
when you play pool on meth,
you know,
you look at a ball and the ball looks
circular.
When I would play on meth,
he said I would see flat surfaces.
So it seemed like a series of flat
surfaces around the ball and I wouldn't
know exactly what flat surface to hit.
So the ball collisions,
like when you play pool,
if you look at a ball and trying to cut
a ball on the side pocket,
you're just kind of estimating where the
ball's going to collide with the other
ball.
And that collIsion point you have to
assume there's going to be like a little
bit of friction.
It's gonna move the ball off the line a
little bit,
especially if you're cutting a ball.
So you've got to kind of compensate
that.
And you add a little spin to it to try
to compensate for the deflection.
So there's all these variables that you
have to kinda like play on feel.
He said it wasn't on feel.
He said when he was on meth he would see
like flat surfaces.
So we knew at this flat surface had to
collide with that flat surface and it
would make like a direct tangent line
that would go into the pocket.
And I was like,
how come you can't see that when you're
sober?
He's like,
I can't even describe to you what it's
like.
He's like,
but when I'm,
when I'm fucked up on meth,
I would see like flat surfaces instead
of a curve was probably a way to mimic
that using some kind of eyewear,
you know?
Yeah.
Probably.
But maybe not because I think what he's
seen as a hallucination,
what he's seen and he's like,
hey,
you get confident in their heads.
It's been big in baseball for ever.
Yeah.
Forever.
make sense?
Right.
Like you would be able to see the ball
coming at you quicker and you maybe will
see the edges of the ball better.
Somebody.
Somebody did say that,
um,
when they were on meth,
like someone was talking about adderall
not on meth,
but adderall,
that they could see the stitches of the
ball as it's coming towards them.
What?
Well,
all that stuff was invented to make
people better.
So that's weird.
All,
all these things that,
you know,
like math and infect means they're all
designed to give you more energy and
make you better at certain tasks.
But we just associated with abuse
because they're illegal.
Weird.
Look,
if adderall and meth really are that
close and no one in this room are smart
enough to understand whether that's
there.
But if they really are and no one in
this room's done math.
Right.
Is that true bro?
And I don't think so.
But you've done adderall,
right?
Yeah.
I wish it did both.
Wait.
Matthew snort might've.
I think.
I feel like I've done it before.
Well,
you can smoke it,
snort it.
The idea is to get it directly into your
bloodstream,
right?
If you're taking the adderall as you're
taking them as a pill so it has to go
through,
your body will start to.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
they do.
Well,
that was one of the things that the
bigger,
stronger,
faster guy had said that when they.
They changed oxycontin's and made them
to where you couldn't smoke them or
snort them.
When you crush them and turn them into a
pill,
their profit margin jumped or dropped by
like 80 percent of you said,
I think it happened after they were here
that it's been approved for 11 year olds
did however know oxycontin's for eight
to 11 year olds.
Cool.
Because everybody knows.
That's why sesame street's on hbo now.
Man.
Shit's changing.
Quick.
Let me do some math and he says to have
aaron and it.
Muppets are gonna.
Fuck.
Finally burton.
Ernie are taking a bath together burden
earning different.
How long those guys been hiding their
true love?
Totally.
Like in those shows like you could have
like two dudes that are obviously adults
live together and nobody questions.
where's the girls?
They don't.
These guys Aren't into girls like bert
and ernie never talked about chicks.
They just hung out together and
practiced with each other.
I'm surprised we don't like homeless
people more because we all loved oscar
the grouch,
you know,
and we kind of grew up as a young kid.
Real loving oscar the grouch.
But then we got older like,
eh,
it's oscar.
get out of here.
What the fuck?
Talking by the way,
that's of red velvet mites.
What I was talking about earlier,
those dots that are around,
they're very small.
Yeah.
You were saying orange.
I was getting confused.
All right,
we'll wrap this bitch up.
We're out of time here.
I'm be back tomorrow with jeff novitsky.
Jeff novitsky vicky's ago,
busted lance armstrong and he now works
for the ufc.
He's a ufc drug guy.
He's going
to clean up the sport.
We're going to find out how,
uh,
Jeff Ross will be here on wednesday.
Should be fun.
Jeff ross is a documentary or his comedy
special comedy central special where he
roasts prisoners.
Awesome.
It's amazing.
And he really did go right into prison
and you know,
and,
and he wrote a really interesting thing
that I re tweeted about it,
that he wrote,
I think he wrote it for huff post about
like how crazy the prison system is and
we'll let him talk about it.
I don't want to go into it.
Uh,
wednesday will be at the ice house.
Brian redman will be there.
Brian count will be there.
I'll be there.
More people to come.
I got a few other people that texted me
during the show that those tickets will
be available soon.
I'll put them up on twitter and about 20
minutes.
this next saturday I'm in austin,
but it's sold the fuck out.
So you snooze,
you lose freak bitches.
Sorry.
You got any dates coming up next
wednesday?
Got secret show at the comedy store.
Belly room.
It's so good.
Belly room version of this show that we
do,
it's going to be the huge belly rooms,
the best.
and then friday,
next friday,
August 28th,
I'll be at the ventura comic con.
I'm doing a show there at the Hong Kong
in,
in ventura,
California.
You tickets are on sale right now and
death squad.tv
for all brian red bands,
tee shirts and shit all sent through
stamps.com
with his own greasy little hands.
If you want to frame him for murder,
you can get some dna off of the packages
and he actually licks each and every one
of those books.
It's funny.
Sometimes I like to throw a shirt in
there and I.
Something else goes into package by
mistake.
Fuck you.
Fat jew.
That's it.
Anything else?
Right?
Amazon and all the people that fat jew
gets money from and tell them what you
think about that.
You get it together.
Fellow.
You don't have to live like this.
You could come up with your own stuff.
Um,
that's it,
right?
Anything else we are going on?
It's basically it.
All right,
we'll see you guys soon.
That's it.
Goodnight.
Bye.
Big kiss.